I think Jose needs a foreskin suit. I think that would be perfect. It's definitely big enough. All right, so as we begin session 12, if any of you guys wanted a review, that's what the Wikipedia is for. Josh, we're going to start off with you. You have, through looking at things that...
might not have been wise to look at with truth saw the writings and the inscriptions and the binding magic and you were reading it and by reading it you tethered yourself somehow to this demon and it has pulled your understanding out of reality and you began to duel for mental control over who will own this
You won a few, and you lost a few. You were not able to break free of the tether. So now, you have to figure out how to handle the situation. So, above board, this is a little bit different than any combat we've done before. Alistair is at the top of the mission. We will deal with the metaphysical, and then we will go into standard initiative. He...
is I'm going to place this dice down. This is actually where he is in reality. He will move and that will be his metaphysical form. He is locked in place. He cannot interact with anything on the plane except for the demon over there and the tether. You have... This is... You guys know this is a big-ass demon. Probably out of your guys' world. However...
If you wish to get involved in fighting him and not the adds, you can. It's your choice. If enough of you go down, which I'm not going to tell you, or you do not defeat the demon at the end of 10 rounds, the paladin will go supernova and destroy it. But he will die as a result. Your goal is to survive and possibly defeat the demon.
The better you guys do at that, the more resources you have for the real work. So, end of round seven. Let's see how things are looking. We may start sprinting. Give us two rounds, guys.
Place yourself where you want on board. This is Alistair, he is locked in place and he cannot move and is defenseless against all attacks. We come in right over here, right? Yeah, you came in here and he stepped forward. I remember I was saying that I was ahead of Alistair, I was right behind him. I was going to say I remember being up front.
Okay, all right, so you got the hammer there I'm going to make This is work so okay These are on top of stuff they are all Crouched on top of these shelves. Oh, they're up above you guys
Come back over here. We have... Alright. I don't have good people because I don't have the right critters. So, this guy with the axe, he's going to be the leonin captain. Katie's character is going to be Penelope. She's going to be standing there. This bird is going to be Kenku. I just lost his name. It wasn't Reggie. Voss. Voss.
Boss. I would know that eagle anywhere. That's an eagle from the Lord of the Rings risk. It is. I know that eagle. He saved Frodo at the end of the movies. And the fox will be Reggie LeDoux. Okay. The four others are other animal folk companions that...
are also here to help fight. We never got into their names. They're the red shirts. Yep, they're the chaff. Okay. So, with this, Alistair, it is the top of initiative. Let's go, Alistair! You have slid behind the pillar and the cord goes through it to him.
What are your desires? Do you want to continue trying to break the tether? Do you want to try to hurt the demon? What are your desires? What do you want? Okay. Considering the situation, I feel like I'm going to get a little bit silly. Alistair's going to come back out of hiding. And where does he see the demon? Yes. You can see the demon. It is the only thing. You can see...
like, vague shapes of other creatures, more goblin, more of like the imps. And you can see twisted spires, and you can see ogre-like demons as well, but they are not things that you can really interact with. They're ghostly to you. The only thing in this reality that is solid as you is the demon. And the tangible yet untangible tether.
got to finish the job she ate two of them and was like this tastes like brother how have you not punched through them it's been three weeks because they're right yeah so he kind of gets a little closer he's like uh actually didn't just throw them out well hello i seem to have misplaced a few of my friends have you seen them just a rabbit talking to a 40 foot tall demon hey you know you've already drooled a little bit over the control and you go and you hide you're like
Okay, let's try conversation. Alright, do you want this to... Are you doing like persuasion? Are you just opening dialogue? Yeah, we're just talking right now. Okay.
looks, his head kind of turns and looks at you and as he came out he was like looking forward at something else in front of him and then he kind of just looks back over you, looks at the cord, he's like, silence word. He's gonna grab the cord and he's gonna jerk. I need you to give me a constitution to the same creature. And the boy contested against.
Let's see, what's my modifier here? Do I still have a plus? Yes. I think it was a d10, yes. 23. As he gives it a yank, you feel his will and his power come into the court, and instead of getting jerked off your feet, you just set them and take the pain. And as it happens, you will take...
two points of damage. However, this was not what he expected as a result. You have him slightly off balance and there is a mental opening because he got a 20 on his. You beat him on this. Would you like to try to do a mental attack or something else? Or would you like to take this opportunity to try to...
use his strength of his yank to possibly dislodge part of this. Yeah, okay. I mean, if he's going to... Let him try to pull it out of you partially or hurt him. Well, I would say, like, if he's going to try and yank that chain, I'll do what I can to make sure he's damaging it in the process. Okay. All right.
You can give me an Arcana check or an Insight check. I'll try Insight. What's the... No, that's terrible. Okay. As he does this, like I said, plant your feet, prepare, you see the opening, you're like, let him do the work for me. So as he does this jerk on you, you feel aspects.
of your soul or spirit as it is attached to it. You take nine points of damage and loss of points. However, this yank has partially severed the connection. It is still connected to you, but it is not as strong as it was before. Wasn't very polite. We're going to move on to Justicar.
Okay, in reality as that plays out, you were looking back at Alistair. Alistair has blood running down the side of his mouth, coming from his nose, his eyes as he's locked up. And then these creatures begin appearing around. And as the Jester car steps forward, he raises his blade, slams it in the ground, and light comes across all of you.
And you all have Holy Weapon on top of yours. So, he moves forward. And he begins his attacks. So for this Holy Weapon, is it basic Holy Weapon or it's altering our weapons to be a Holy Weapon? Holy Weapon. You imbue Weapon with Holy Power.
The weapons shine 30 feet radius and dim light for an additional 30 feet. The weapon attacks deal an extra 2d8 radiant damage. If it's not magic, it becomes one with the duration. On your bonus action on your turns, you can dismiss the spell and cause it to emit a burst of radiance. Each creature you can see of your choice within 30 feet must make a con save. Failed save, 48 radiant or be blinded for a minute. Consecutive saves at the end of their turn.
So he can drop it, but for now on you guys have the spell right now. So that's a plus 2d ingredient. So you're augmented. Yes, you're augmented. It is concentration, correct? It is concentration up to 1 hour. So even with his things, these rolls were critical. So with that first round of his spell and his attacks, he does not connect. Damn!
Which brings us to the... I told you I didn't want to invade Iraq. Middle East. Okay. Since you just attacked him... Okay. So, as the justicar takes the first few swings at him, he blocks it with his club in his hand. The first one. He parries the second. Then he swings out with his whip.
strikes the justicar and you guys hear a rending tear as the plate mail across his chest takes a cut it cuts clean through it on a crit and as
The just car kind of steps back. He then brings the mace around and slams it into the side of his Wing and you hear a cracking sound as a second crit lands on the justic. Oh, I just did this just go getting fucked up He said ten rounds the demon said nah to to Check so good. Sorry, just car up
a miss on another attack. So, seeing this, Rurik is going to come running off. Rurik? Go ahead, yeah. He is going to run past him to this position, and he is going to make a series of attacks. Okay, the first one is a miss, the second is a crit, the third one is a hit.
Okay, um at least we have the fat man there ready to introduce the demon to Japan in 1945 Hell yeah That's what it's all about baby. That's what it's all about USA USA USA USA USA I don't know about this animation So, um as he crits on it on that on that attack
It is at that moment that the demon is going to use a reaction and make an attack at him. This is an attempted grapple. It is... I'll tell you guys above the board, it is a dexterity 17. That is a natural 1. Guys, so...
As he comes down, this 40-foot demon grabs him and picks him up. And as he brings him up, this is a... It was an actual natural one. But, guys, if you'd like to use reaction, if you can damage the arm 30 points consecutive between you, he won't be here. I don't have any reactions I can use here.
I mean, you can use your... So what I'm going to allow you to do is if you have a ranged attack, you can burn your reaction to make an attack. I'm going to do that. This is a thing I'm doing in the game. You guys can use your reaction to make an attack to try to prevent this. Is he a fiend? Yes, fiend. You have to get 30 points of damage in consecutive to keep him from...
11 plus 9 on the roll. 11 plus 9 for a 20? Yes. That is a miss. Well guys. Okay, does anyone else want to use your reaction to make a range attack? I guess I'll throw... I mean, I gave away all my Aether Pistols and all my guns. Well, I kept one Aether Pistol. But that's a plus 3 to hit. So I think I'm going to throw a Javelin.
That's an 8. Nate, you wanna make a ranged attack? Our only ranged character is possessed right now. I was trying to see what my range was on my Horde, but it's only, I think, 20. So, not near close enough. So... Reaction. I eat your homie. Literally.
I was not- I got rid of most of my guns. I don't remember which ones I have left. You kept the shotgun I think, right? I'm pretty sure I kept the shotgun, but I'm like 50 feet away so... Shotgun, no patch. I have one pistol and one shotgun. Whichever one has the better price. I guess I'll just use the pistol. Well, it's out of range for that too.
I can physically do enough damage to him, but... I mean all my reactions I need to be in melee range for, so I'm kind of screwed here. I'm going to use one of my Squire of Salomea Precision Strikes. So you have advantage on your attack and you want to reroll it? Yep. Okay, let's do that before we say you used yours. I will let him do this.
14 plus 9. 23. That's a miss! We're level 3, Logan! We're cunts! What just missed? A 23! There are ways to do this, but... On the arm, holy shit! On the arm, bro! Okay, I might have an idea. What... What size is this guy?
He's 40 feet. So huge? Or he's... Gargantuan? I think 40 is gargantuan. He would be in the upper huge, lower gargantuan. Okay, so... So... He's going to take him and put him in his mouth and bite down and chew a couple times. So...
He is going to... Excuse me. What sucks is that I got a perfectly good range weapon for this exact scene. I have the Holy Adventure Heavy Crossbow. Hell yeah.
Alright. Then it's a 1d10 plus 7, and then a 2 additional d10. Alright. So he takes 67 points of damage. Ow! And he is... However, he then takes him and throws him.
Across the room. Bro takes a couple bites, says, he's armored, I can't get in there that quick. I don't want to play with you anymore. Tosses him across the fucking room. Just a taste. Rurik takes an additional... Hey! He takes additional damage from the throw hitting the wall. So, guys, if you crit, he will do this to you.
If you... crit on his ass, he just picks us up. We're trying to just hit the motherfucker. If you crit, and you were within melee range, he will make this attempt on you. As long as he has his reaction. He is a bad mofo. This is a dick. So, Rurik is not dick. He is... Fucking Pokemon low health sound effect.
So, Rick is level 16. He just got his ass beat. He hits the wall, kind of slides down, but he is not prone. So, next in initiative is Captain Havlin.
After seeing this he's like, nope. And he's going to come over here, step up here, and going to attack the little smaller demon things. That is a crit for him. Second crit! Logan, I'm going to need you to chill out on those crits. I don't care that you're rolling for us as well. If it's no, it's just for the allies. Okay. First imp is killed.
Is it middle one, left one, right one, whichever? The one right there, yes. I guess that would be him. It's considered humanoid. Because, oh, I forgot. Blessed weapon on those crits. I did not add in that extra damage.
Bless weapon, let me come back here and roll it. 2d8, correct? 2d8 per attack. Which would be doubled because it's against a fiend, and then doubled again because it's a crit. So that is 12, which is 24, doubled is 48 additional points of damage on that crit. Additional 48. Okay, with that...
Captain is going to make his two attacks. He is going to use the rest of the movement to jump up here and he is going to action surge and crit. Okay, minimum that one's dead. I have a question. Are the Eagler Crystals inert or reactive if they were like...
to be said in an explosion like shot with a plasma um ether crystals are the base for so if they were shattered you could have a magical place in claymore yeah okay not for real so next in initiative is reggie reggie is going to step up to alistair look at you for a moment
put his hands on either side of your shoulders and he is going to channel the healing spell into you. You get 20 points of healing. It was a really... So I don't know how much that helps, but I think it helps. It helps for sure. And then he is going to stand in front of you.
whatever threat is going to come at you. Oh, okay, that's fine. Technically that was supposed to be Penelope's turn, so you don't have that, but we'll just end that for the moment. I'll click the wrong button. All right, Penelope, she's gonna move up to here and...
She's partially blocked from line of sight from this guy. She's going to use the pistol that you gave her and she's gonna take a shot at one of these imps. She has never done this before so that is a natural one. However, she looks at it. He's got loaded dice. 1s and 20s are super loaded for him. However, she looks at it, does a two-hand stance, and gets a hit on the next shot.
as a but as a holy it was two um okay so she does a wackadoodle on buggy boy and that actually brings us to um so i did that backwards 35 okay um so everyone pretty lousy um in initiative so now it is the hamsters and these creatures okay
This one is going to... He's going to make a ranged attack at our dwarf on the ground with magic missile. So they hit. Oh, that's a cheap shot. Okay, he takes eight points of damage. The second imp is going to... Who's closest to him?
I guess that would be... Are you behind the pillar so he can't see you or are you just... Okay. All right, he's going to take a shot at our dear Jefferson. This one is a Firebolt. AC is 19 currently. That is a miss on that. This brings us to one here. He is going to fly at the Justicar.
And he is going to try to latch onto him. This will be contested. Okay, yeah. The justicar has no issue. This one here is going to fly up. And he's going to start an action that's going to take more than one round. This guy is going to jump off and come running up to our dwarf.
And he's going to make a series of attacks at you, sir. He just has a small green targeting laser. Does a 21 hit you, sir. It's a miss. He comes in and makes two swipes at you with his evil claws. Both miss. This guy's going to jump down and come up on Vosk. Okay. Luckily, both of those miss.
Jefferson, it is your turn. Okay. I'm going to start this big guy. Can I make an insight check and see how dexterous I believe he is? He's very large. And considering what we've seen thus far, I'm sure he has legendary resistances. But for something I'm planning on trying in the future, I'm curious on inciting what I think his dexterity abilities would be. Okay. So I'm going to make an insight.
Plus the d4. Thir-teen. Sixteen. Just super, kind of, not really. Okay. Better than you would expect for someone that size. Not a good save. Okay. I do have a pretty good save for my level, and I do have a Faerie Fire, but I'm not going to start with that. I am going to start, I'm going to bonus action cast Shield of Faith on myself. So I'm going to buff my AC by two. I will...
Move to engage. I'll move 5, 10. Get flanking. Get flanking bonus here. And I'm going to use my quick strike. So whenever I have advantage, I may split it to two separate attacks. Gotcha. So I'm going to do that. So these are two attacks at plus 11. Those aren't great.
I have a... well, 17 and a 19, I guess. Both hits. Plus 11 does a lot, I guess. Each one of these are going to be 2d12 plus 2d8 radiant. So that's 8 radiant. Which is 16. To 16, and then that's...
23 plasma, fire, whatever damage this weapon deals. You've nuked him. I nuked him on the first shot? Yeah, they have 35 hit points. Okay, so first one goes away. So I have moved 15. I will move another 510 to get a flanking on this one, attacking the justicar. Bonus action.
Oh, you still have another hit. So yeah, since I nuked him on my first attack, my second attack was also a hit. Is it the same armor class for this guy? Yes. Okay. Did not think I would nuke him in one shot. So, let's see what the roll is on this one. Okay, so that's 1625 of the plasma, and then another 8, double to 16 radiant. That gets him. Okay. So, drops those two.
and now I'm within five feet of just the car. I have some reactions I may be able to take between now and my extra, but that is all for me. Okay. This guy is going to come. He is going to throw a javelin at the guy up in the air. That is a natural one. This is his. 25. He is going to shoot the bow.
Oh, I put one attack in the mask. Look at that. Just misses. That is his. This way. That gum! He misses. Finally, the hit will be... Okay. Uh... Joss. Joss. Jose. Jose. Joss. Jossie! J-O-S. Yep, with an E. Jossat! Jossat. Jossat. I'll send my drone.
20 going out how high is this guy up like another 10 feet yeah because he was already on that he was he was about 10 feet up before he started okay so i think i'd be like five feet below maybe ten feet all right um i'm going to attempt to zappy zap him all right you gotta remind me it's con right uh yep 16 calling nat one well
He quits flying and falls as he is stunned. He will take damage on the way down. No idea what he was doing, but anything that takes more than one turn to do, that ain't good. Yeah, well, he is stunned and falls away and hits the ground. Is this object...
Also that high? Yeah, it's about... that one's about... those are about 10 feet up on the ground. Okay. They're bookshelves or pillars. Five, ten... I mean, you're seven, eight foot tall. And I've got 40 feet of movement. I'm 10 feet from it. I think I can make it to the top of that. Yeah, you could. Yeah. I'm going up here. And I'm gonna make a couple swings. In piece? No, that's in piece. So...
So I've got a nat 20, and a 28, and then I've got a 13. So, basic mat, nat 20, plus you have the 2d8. So that's going to be... roll your 2d8 real quick. We'll just find out if this works, but it's probably just an insecular. I got 2 and a 4. Okay, that's 6, which is 12, which is 24. Can you get 11 damage?
Probably considering it's a 4d6. It's equipped so yeah, you need a 5. 5 damage, you can get 5 damage. Roll the dice and get 5 damage. Well it would be double. 2, 3, 4, 5. Okay, so easily 5 doubled. So 14 and 28. Yeah.
Was that the flying boy or? That one over here. Flying boy got stunned and fell. So I ran over to this other one that was closer. The drone beep boops I have the high ground. Yeah, exactly. Alright, you honestly still have about 10 to 15 feet. Would you like to jump across? Over to the other one? Yeah. Yeah. Just give me a little acrobatics to make sure you make the leap. Oh, I have advantage on acrobatics.
That might be helpful. No, no, no. Seven, nine, fifteen. You make it. It's not, it's just a ten foot jump and you're seven foot tall. I'm a big old boy. Um, so that's second attack? Well, I rolled two attacks on the other one. Okay. Well, because I was just going to double swing on him. I do have bonus action though, which I believe I can take a third.
Yeah, I believe that's correct. With your gloves, you can use a bonus action for another attack. I'm pretty sure. If not, you're in position. I'm pretty sure it's under one of the properties, isn't it? Yeah. Because light property allows a two-weapon. We're following your next turn. We'll be up after the... We're at 14. You're on deck.
So yeah, I can make one more attack as a bonus action. So I want to swing on this guy. So I was a little off my game from the jump. That's a 1. Okay. So as we hit this point in the initiative, you hear a bit of a odd noise. Alistair, you had seen the spiders in the other room.
Spiders. Trouble.
These glowing giant spiders begin to materialize. Aw hell no. Glowing? They have veins of the same demon blood that you have seen in here that looks like it's infected them. So, are rainy demons still- They are still some kind of demonic thing. Aww. Those are some big ass spiders, damn. Uh, yes.
And as they enter in, first things first, I need you to give me a dexterity saving throw as it hawks this. So you've fought spiders before and you're expecting this. So give me a dexterity. That's going to be a one plus eight. So as you expect the web to come, you've dodged these before.
But this isn't what comes flying out. This strange, glowing, poisonous black tar, like the stuff you walked by, but it has demonic blood mixed into it, is hacked out, and as it hits you, you immediately will take... Talk to a... Eleven points of necrotic damage.
I need a constitution saving throw. 17. Okay. As it hits you, you take the burn, but you're able to just kind of like flick it off of you. It doesn't stick to you. You are not poisoned. The fighter is going to run and make a lungy leap attack at our lion. He is going to also make a dex save, and he makes it.
As the spider flings past him, he's going to do an attack of opportunity against it. So, if the spider lunges and you dodge it, you can whack it. Hell yeah. If you haven't already used your... Whack. Yep, that is a hit. It is demonic, so it's going to take double damage on these two dice. And roll it. Oh, I'm on your page. I shouldn't be rolling on your page. I should be rolling on this page. We're rolling back.
Oh nice! That is 26 plus... So as that guy goes flying by, he just spins around and just slashes it as it comes flying past and literally splits it down the middle and kills it. Damn! Ah, that's horrible. He maxed damage on everything but one damage die.
Oh, obviously. He had a 7 and a 6 on the... Anyway. Okay. The next spider is going to make a spitting attack at your flyer. Dron, watch out! C2. So it's a deck save? Yep. Be professional or not at that. I mean, he is a flyer. I think he probably...
So if it's not... Would he have the same proficiency as me? Like the two? Yeah. So that would be a six. 17. 17 is a save. It misses it as he flicks out of the way. Let's go! Spider is going to do the Lunger Tech at you, Zach. Okay. Next save, 15. I have plus four. That is a 16.
Okay, would you like to make? Go ahead your turn I have my turn my reaction is back So here's I can I can take a hit for somebody if I want to I don't know if I want to take a hit from that demon to save the I got it. I got it. I got it vaporized. So yes, I will take it on the spider
That's a strike two to hit. Yeah, that'll hit. Okay, I'll start with radiant damage and keep that separate. That is... Let me see what the other damage is because I might reroll this with savage attacker. I am going to reroll this with savage attacker. That's better. So that's going to be 20 radiant damage already doubled. Okay. And then 1625. That's it. It's dead. Hey, why'd you throw it my way?
Keep them close, keep them close. I was gonna say, these are not the only ones we're fighting. I'm gonna move over to this little... I'm assuming, is it the little gremlin guy over here? Yeah, he's on the ground. I'm gonna get a main-inch person next to them. 14 plus 12 to hit. That'll hit. Also, keep in mind you have a plus one to all-dam. Oh, wait a minute.
It's a plus one because of Holy Weapon, correct? No, Holy Weapon does not give advice to attack. It's only damage. My plus one is if I do Reckless Attack version. Yeah. Five on the axe. Nine total on the first. Nine. Oh, I have it in my read. Seven plus nine plus, so 19 plus 26. 26. Okay. Proof seven.
And then since I reduced it, I get another attack. The one on the ground is laying there. It's not dead. You have advantage on attack. True. Yeah, it should be directly under the thing. It just, I didn't have room for it on the floor. Yeah, that right there. That'll do. Alright. No.
Jack, how are you incapable of rolling on a table? Well, I mean, it bounced so much. I mean, at this table, you can at least make the excuse of like, there's not a ton of room. There's not a ton of room. The table I have. Well, that was because I know there's so much room, so I just fucking send it too much. That is a hit. All right, cool. That was a six and a three. 21. 21? Give me a lecture.
That is a 16 on the luck check. Okay, uh, you will- Yippee! Bonus action. Yeah, I think that's everything. Um, technically, you get- If you do to zero, don't you get an additional attack without a bonus action? No.
If I hit a critical or reduce a creature to zero, I can make one extra melee attack with the bone section. Gotcha. So I've done everything I can do. I've done movement, I've done everything. The only thing I have is reaction, so I'll pass the turn. Pass the turn. Okay guys. Ice Cool. As you put those couple down, there is a kind of distortion by the table into large
Demons appear. Now they are... These are about the size of an ogre. And they're an aunt. What? So like 15, 20 feet? Yeah. That come in. Come? I need someone to roll me a d6. I'm ready to volunteer. Five. Okay.
With that, we are... Alright, we are all the way back up to the top. Alistair, you have hurt yourself a lot trying to yank that out, but you think that if you could do something similar, you could sever it from me. However, you are getting... I will let you give me an Arcana or an Insight check for free. Let's go with Arcana. That's going to be 23.
Alright. You are dealing with this demon in a metaphysical way. You can take damage. It can take damage. But with the echoes of pain that is echoing through it, you know that the damage you're doing in this reality does more damage than what's going on. If you sever this, you will re- you will break this and probably get back up there. But you can do a lot more damage in this reality than outside.
but not necessarily from direct attack. You might be able to, but he might retaliate as a direct attack against you here. It is your choice. You are partially severed. Okay. I'm going to try to break the tether this turn. What would you like to do then? So Alistair kind of... There's like a little... There's like a table or something here. Yeah. He kind of hops up on this table and takes a seat.
He's like, I hope you don't mind if I take a moment here. It's quite a long march. He pulls out like a ration or something.
Boy, I wish this was a piece of pie, though. Blueberry pie. Or strawberry pie. Is Alistair rage-baiting this demon? I think he might. What's your favorite kind of pie? How about a cream pie? Just take a minute and think about it. Oh, my goodness. Oh, psychological warfare.
Bro, this rabbit is making this demon's life hell for this minute of combat.
So, I roll to see how he would respond.
She has a brain aneurysm and dies.
Cool.
Let's see what that...
I'm actually not a big fan of pies.
I'm a big fanof a knuckle sandwich.
Roll me the d10.
Oh my god.
Just the d10?
I choose green pie.
And so will you.
He unsheathes his massive weapon.
No!
Narduk.
You are reduced to atoms in the metaphysical plane.
Is that what you would like to spend your turn doing? Anything else?
Well, I mean...
Rage beat hard track.
So, uh, I just don't...
I would like...
Okay, I will say...
I'm looking, I guess...
At how he responds?
Well, yes, but for anything...
Anything that seems like I could have backed, I guess.
Okay, so...
let him take a single reality in this place.
Alright, so as you sit there and start eating the ration, and his attention shifts
yet again from the Esmir to you. The one you rolled, he is distracted. The next person
to attack him to have advantage over his attacks.
Let's go.
Huge.
He raged me in so hard.
Put me in, coach.
You legitimately raged me.
Put me in coach.
I'm ready to play today.
So, I will let you, since you're trying to glean more information about this, do you
want to, what do you think you would roll?
Is it arcana?
Tell me specifically, are you talking about this reality, this between world where you've
been pulled into it?
pulled into it.
What is it that you're trying to glean from this? Okay, how about the question is whether I'm more likely to be effective by messing with the place or by messing with him? Okay, I would say, why don't we use the rest of your turn? Give me a perception and then an insight based on those two. Go ahead and add the d10 to both, like we said.
which we'll find out I'll tell you later after this plays out what then okay as you look around you can see basically
the spirits, the dimensional fabric of wherever these demons and creatures are coming through that he is summoning as they are passing by. You're not quite in sync with the... Why don't you now give me the arcana, or the inside check. Okay.
They seem to be entering and passing through this reality from two spots. Specifically, between these two and those two torches. The majority of them. These guys, you don't know where they came from. You didn't see them pass through. But you are seeing the small man pass through this plane. Okay.
So this will bring us to the Justicar. He's Justicar after Missing the crit are missing the attacks and seeing what's on either side He is going to I want you all Since he has advantage because of the distractions
his bonus action to search to search in vigor and make a set of decks again okay he's going to action search oh my gosh second that's third crit fourth crit so he got four crits and he gets three attacks per thing so he got four crits and he missed eight types
Yeah, please roll this guys So all these are no standard kids Wow for grits Okay, so I'm just gonna roll everyone wants your cheesy balls in their mouth Just not it not all the time Look I can only handle your cheesy balls about once every few weeks
And only for a few minutes at a time. That's fair. What the fuck did I just watch? Okay. A lot of dice. 85 double. 170. Double. 340. He does 340, uh, 340 to it. Boy. Um, the demon is going to be pissed and use his reaction. Speed bag in the demon's bag. Um. Robot bag.
This is a dex save and he makes it. Nobody needs the justicar. Okay, it is... Yeah, so all of his damage is radiant damage, justicar's. So, okay. It is the greater demon's turn. There is going to be a miss on the justicar. That is a miss on the justicar that is hit. Are these arranged?
He's swiping on the just. And then that is missed. He only hits him once. He's 40 foot, his arm. He's 40 feet. So he only gets one hit on the just a card. Oh, the big demon guy. Gotcha. I thought when you said greater demon you meant the... Sorry, the big ass demon. I was thinking he was kind of more like a demon lord. Okay. And he tanks those.
Next initiative is Rurik. Rurik! Yo, Rurik, drink a health potion, bro. I see the teeth marks in your plate. He's going to stand up, and he's going to reach into his cloak, and he's going to pull out a wand, and he's going to fire it the big demon on the left of the massive guy who just spawned in.
So, uh, the demon fails. Is it the one with never-ending bates? No. It does 42 points of damage. He's going to put it back in there, and then he's going to begin to move back 30, 35, and he's gonna get his face. Damn. Little boy's got some movement. Yeah. That guy.
Tours were meant for sprints. Are you getting dressed to watch Warcraft Destructions? Close to him. Alright, he's going to use a feature. So, the Justicar, Zach, Nate, and our lion, you guys get 20 to hurry it. Nice. Next in initiative. [Review note: the resource granted with this 20 is unclear.]
Here's the ogres. Ogres, demons. We'll start with the one right in front of Rurik. He has advantage, he is going to make an attack. As he does, that is a miss. Rurik is going to use his reaction from a miss and make an attack on him. That is a crit and he is dead. This one? Yeah. Rurik, stop killing him so fucking fast, dude. What the hell?
Bro said I smite thee. He said I'm pissed you didn't. I just got the throne market. Don't worry. Yeah, no, the elon's coming for me. Yeah, alright. As he comes at you, he's going to make a swing at you. AC is 21. He telegraphs and misses. And then he crit- not once, I'm sorry. Critical fails. Okay. Next attack. I was about to say-
Man, that's why hit points were really good when he had them. With a critical fail. Next, the Justicar. The Justicar, he's left himself open. So Justicar is going to take a moment to take a swipe at him since he's right there. Okay. He has advantage because of you. Yeah, because flanking. Which means that that is going to hit. Let's see the damage. You good, man?
Every time I look over you're wiping your eyes. Are you okay? Why are you looking at me? 64 points of damage. Huge. Damn, these ogres are pussies. Be glad because they come back every round. Yeah, I know. We're at the beginning of round two. I know. Alright, Kevin Hadlock. He is going to...
Step over here and get advantage because of you sir And that is a hit see if that's enough to kill bug boy It is not well, but way hasn't been damage since I'll go ahead and roll the second attack two hits all right Will be two days was to be a hit this way with the compelled duel and then run
Oh, I forgot to double the 8s. Oh, it doesn't break it down, does it? It should. It just says 23. It doesn't tell me which. It is 1, 8, 1, 3, 2, 1, 3, 1, 1, 2. So 1, 8. Okay, so 1, 8 would have been at least.
Okay, I forgot to do that. So okay he puts that one down because of the slow gag. Okay, and he's gonna stand next to you sir and face the spider. Is the spider on the wall or down on the ground below? Wall. He's about even with you. Across. And it's about 10 feet to the wall, yeah? Yeah. Okay, Penelope. Penelope is going to shoot the big deal.
Let's go Penelope! I'll be honest, how far am I? A couple initiatives? No, initiative turn order. Because I know more things spawned in between me and the other initiative. You are two if more does not spawn. Oh, that is a hit. Wait, yeah that is a hit. How did she do that? Plus 2d8. 13, 9 doubled is 8.
18 plus, uh, what did I say? 13. Plus 13. Yes, uh, 31. Okay. She did that. That will, um, take her second shot. Crit! Nat 20. Yeah! Does he fucking reach out across the map and eat her? Uh, not melee. Well, he's got a 40-foot melee. I'm sure the whole 40-foot melee.
Okay, okay, so she's right on the cuffs. I think he's 45 feet. 15 plus... I keep forgetting just how good he is. 18. 15 plus 18 is 34 doubled. 84 doubled? No, 34 doubled. Okay, 68? 68 points of damage on that crit.
Let's go! I'll be honest, if it gets to my turn and nothing else is spawned, I might have no other target than the big bad guy, so I might end up swinging in on him for a couple hits. How far is she? 45? He is going to use his ranged reaction, which is a Kona Firebird. I do not consent. I said, no, no, don't touch me there. This is my show.
This cone is big and different. It is con saves to see if you can take half the damage. I love that. Is my drone high enough? Okay. Damn. Notoriously dogged against. 19. Okay, 19 will pass. I was going to say, that's a really low roll for me as well. Yeah, I was going to say, you will pass. Adjust your car.
Oddly enough, 84 damage. Will... Reduce to half. ...fail any... Wow, okay. Hey, 21! 21, you're good. Yeah, let's go! Let's get it! Failure. Vosk is a failure. Penelope is a success. Yeah! If the drone's in...
Well, he's also 40 feet up breathing down to the drones only what 20 feet. Oh, yeah, that's Yeah, okay Reggie fails. I mean regardless you hands right out of range going down Would have hit you you're at 55 I Do what you roll? Yeah, it'll catch you. Oh, okay. That's why I was trying to say
Okay. You. And that's for half damage? Yes. So those of you who pass take 15 points of damage. Everyone else takes 30. I'm down to 5 temporary hit points. Magic Missiles. God damn it. Good thing I don't care about your character. Good thing. Is your drone still up? He has 30 with his overshield. Okay, so he's at 15 out of 20. No one is down. But, um...
Yeah, so if you do a range attack and you crit, he will do a nasty thing to you. Okay, he's used one reaction thus far, right? Correct. Or has he used two? This is his first reaction. Okay, guys. As we get to this point in initiative, this is where the imps spawn back. Oh, yeah, he got cooked. Or you beat the crap out of him.
So this one's going to come in, spawn in, yeah, there will be a, yeah, he's going to come in right on top. This one here. Or this one is going to come in basically right below him. Here. Here. And this one's here. Fine. Okay. So, first off, the first round is going to make attack at our lion.
That will be a miss. The next one is going to attack our lion. That will be
a hit.
Damage. Well that's pitiful, which is great. Couple ones on those decks.
Alright.
Uh, he still has temporary hit points.
That's good.
Because of flanking, this guy will have advantage on you.
Juan.
And with advantage, he will miss.
The other Mexican J name.
Jose.
Not Juan.
Josie.
Jesus.
Jesus!
Okay, so the one closest to me on this side.
He's going to start the multi-round cast. Going to the one that spawned in close to
here, he's going to charge at you, Zach, and he's going make a bite attack at you, and
your 20 what? 21, pardon me.
That has missed him. Next one's gonna jump down and run to the same spot, and he is going
to Hitch. Give me a constitution saving throw, or con save.
22.
Alright, you pass. You will not take any effects from this other than 10 points of damage.
Okay, I'm out of 10 hit points, I have 259.
Okay.
The flier is going to fly up and make an attack on the drone with a 2 for a miss. Bartholomew, this one is going to jump down on you. 22 is a miss. Yeah, he's up there. So 22 is a miss on you. That brings us...
to Reggie's turn. Reggie did not like that fire breath. It burns his stuff. So Jefferson, since you're next initiative, he's going to give you a bardic inspiration. Let's go! Which is a d8 for him. A d8? Alright. Sounds good. And he is going to do a quick look around. I was too much here. A6.
He is going to give Penelope a clean one. Okay? And that will end his turn. Jefferson, you are up. Well, I got some boys in front of me now. Let me check something real quick. I guess I'll just start. I'll make an attack on the one on my left. I don't believe I get any advantage. I don't have anyone else within my feet.
First attack is a 24. That is a hit. From the left. I'll roll the damage for that. That will be... I'm gonna roll a 12 to see if I want to use my savage attacker. I am going to use savage attacker on this attack. So that's going to be 16 radiant. 16 already doubled. Already doubled. That's... 17 points of plasma. That will finish that one. Okay. And then I will use my bonus action, backswing, hit the one on the right.
21 to hit. 21 will hit. Do you get an extra attack after a crit, or is that not unlocked yet? So I do not get extra attacks on crit. Okay, it's not unlocked. You have to upgrade. I was gonna say, the blade... I was just looking at this earlier. I might be thinking the wrong way. So the blade has a crit range of 19 through 20 baseline. And when I crit, I destabilize them.
and the dealing 3d sex extra fire and the amulet of Hestia just gives me a bonus action back swing attack when I take the attack action. So I guess yeah you as you upgrade the weapon if you get more upgrades. Yeah I can either so the first upgrade is lower crit range second upgrade is an extra damage die third upgrade is a plus four armor class bonus. That's right that's right.
So damage on this second attack is going to be 26 radiant damage. And then 15, 24. 24 and 26? Oh yes, 20, so like 50 total damage on the hit. So both of those guys go away. That is action, bonus action. And I still have, right now again, have my reaction to use.
And yeah, I guess I'll just sit here standing beside big boy. Okay. Guarding the Justicar's flank. He's gonna come up. He's going to yet again try to throw up at the guy up top. Missed last time, and he misses again this time. He's gonna shoot the bow at the one on top of the looser, and it's also a miss.
Yeah, red shirts, definitely red shirts. Okay. Juan! You're right. Josie. Jose. I gotta just remember you're a hoe. With a J. Shotgun is 15? Or is it 30? It's 30. Because they take damage regardless. 10, 20, 30? Yeah. They have disadvantage on their con save within 10 feet.
Anything past 20 they have advantage. Okay I'm gonna jump the gap back over here and push past this guy right here. Okay. So I need a acrobatics again. He's gonna take a check of opportunity. That is a crit miss. It was a critical miss. I keep saying that wrong. 13. Yeah. He made it. 12's the thing for that jump. Sweet. So you're gonna try to
So then I'm now going to shotgun blast these four guys. Okay. Guy in front has disadvantage. That is a failure. The guy across from him is a straight roll. That is a failure. The spider has advantage and pass, so take half damage. And the other guy with advantage is equal. The spider has advantage. He's only... Oh.
How far is he? He's 15. He's three spiders. Oh, okay. Then I will reroll. He rolled a 17 and 18. Oh, so, okay, my bad. I thought he was just out. So, uh... He should be straight, and then the middle little guy is straight, and then the far guy is advantage. And the advantage guy you missed. Okay, so the three little dudes... Fail. Fail. Spider passed. So, roll your damage, and I'll mark it. That's...
a wrong amount of damage. It's going to be 24. 24 standard plus your... Okay. And then 12 doubled to 24. So 44. Okay.
You killed the 3 imps flat out? Yeah! Spider heat lead bastards! So that was 42, so he'll take half damage, which is 21 points. Okay, that is your action. I forgot I also have the other thing that does more damage on shotgun blasts. So how much more? Seven force damage. So give me a look.
10. It is still up. Yeah. I don't think it can get pushed anywhere really since it's kind of flat on the wall already. That's the other part of the shotgun. That'll be your turn. Bonus action that I can really do. So yeah, that'll be it. Okay guys, at this point in the initiative, no more spiders. Nor...
I'm starting to see why he said just stay alive. Okay, this one is going to come up on him. I'm going to do the... He's going to do a lunge attack. Let's see if he can dodge. Okay. That is a failure. The dwarf is knocked prone. And the spider is going to chew on this one. Yep, spider's on top. Khan safe. He has advantage of the dwarf. That is a pass on that.
He is going to take 18 points of damage. And he is crap. And next, deck save for the lion. Quack! He failed. This one hits him and knocks him off and has pinned him to the ground. Con save. He makes it. That is 20 points of damage.
The one that you just shot at is going to... I need a dex save from you, sir. It does the same weak thing. It's feeling lucky. Garn. 17. Alright. Would you like to make an opportunity attack as it misses you? As it spins past you? Yeah. Punch a red and spin her in. Oh, maybe not. That's going to be an 11. What does it miss as it flies past you? Okay.
These spiders are going to come aggressively towards our leaves. He's flanking. He has got advantage on this. He is just going to come in and bite attack at you. You said 23 for the Dwarf's Health, or is it 24? For you, is it 23 or 24? ACZ. ACZ. 23. Okay, that is a miss. Second is just a miss. Dex save as this one lunges at you.
You are knocked prone as the spider lands on top of you. You need a con save, I think you have it for poison and you should have advantage on that. Yes I do. That's gonna succeed. 19 plus 8. Yeah. Okay, you are not poisoned. You take...
16 points of damage and are grappled and... Is it poison damage? No, uh, binding damage. Zach. Yes, our cons. Dexterity save. 10. Okay, I need that con save. You are also knocked prone. 22. You are not poisoned.
Golly. Howie! 22 points of damage. Gee! Almost max damage. Can you not, please? Okay, this brings us to the guy the spider just almost landed on. He's going to make an attack, and he has advantage because of flanking. That is going to be a hit. Damage to the spider. Nope, nope.
I need to roll those separate. But anyway, Spidey... He is dead. Kill the spider. Okay, we can remove Wolfie. Next guy is going to run up. He is going to try to help their leader with an attack. Just makes it. So I'm going to roll the radiant first, which is 24 plus... 24, 28 plus...
Oh, just made it 30. He kills this writer. Considering these guys have been missing, yeah. Alright, sir. Bartholomew. I'm going to stand back up. Now, practically surrounded. Yeah. Now, he has got you grappled in his jaws as you kind of wrestle yourself up. I'm going to use that.
I'm going to do my reckless attack. Okay. Your precision. Natural 20. Natural 20. Correct. I think that's practical. Yeah, that's a dead. It's possible to not kill him. Remove one. Yep. So, let's see. This one was the one that jumped on me, so I'll strike him first.
And then, once I hit a crit, I am able to once again use a bonus action to attack again. I double-checked that Reckless Attack. I think I can just... I think it's... Just get to do it again. I don't think there's a... Yeah, it's a different version of Reckless. You activate it, and you get on your attacks. Yeah, so I'll do it again. I really wish I had a little bit of crit range.
Barely miss a crit, but it's a 19 plus 12, so that's a hit. Aren't you... We have not lowered crit range. You're one level shy, aren't you? Yeah. Like one or two, I can't remember. Anyway, it doesn't matter. We're going to do tech rolls. Radiant damage, three. Fuck. Let's see if I can roll this. I don't know.
Come on Jack, you got it. That's a lot better. Uh, 11, 10 is 21, and then 7 times 2, 14 radiant. Okay, uh, yeah, you nipped that one too. Okay. Spiders off the board. I don't have any more attacks. Dammit. I'm thinking, is that the updated one? Because we switched you off of your one level of barbarian to three champion, didn't we? Yeah.
Okay, so three champion did we take fell so when you crit? Okay, that's the one we took instead of doing the crit range. Okay. I just wanted to make sure because I was like that's why I was saying as soon as I hit that crit I'm like that spiders not bliffing. Yeah. Yeah, fell is kind of disgusting. Two additional damage dice. Yeah, I don't think I've got any more attacks. Yeah. My bonus action. So I will
Yeah, that's it. That's all I got. Okay guys, um... Thing went. Okay. At the bottom of initiative, there is a Shimmer and a Blur and two more big guys step in. Oh god, bless! I need someone else to roll me. Oh gosh, you got... Oh, I got it. Four. A nuclear bomb spawns at the top of the arena.
A special infected with a gravity hammer pops out from behind the door. Bro, Halo 2 Jackal Sniper is on the roof. Oh god no! Is a 4 a good roll or a bad roll? Let's see. 4! Alright guys, we are beginning round. So, piece of advice, or a note. The D6 is the combat in the other room with the other game.
Okay. That roll determines a ratio of casualties. And then we roll to see who gets killed. So, we will find out what happens. Bro, we're going to have to deal with the other demon too. No deal. Alistair. If I were in your guys' shoes, I would leave. My character's not. But now we got this.
We were chatting like end of turn seven if we're all still alive and we evaluate the situation. And if it's still not looking great, we're fucking starting the run so we can be out of here by end of turn ten. When he goes nuclear. We'll help for seven or eight turns, but past that, he's going fat man and I don't want to be here when that happens. He was also discussing something else, but we'll see at the end of turn three or four.
I have a spicy idea. This will be a very, if it's what I think it is, this will get very interesting. It's not the music box. Okay, good. I will be blunt. This is a place of power. And if you crack that sucker open here, bad things happen. Can I do it? Would it be beautiful? Unless I'm not good at doing ideas.
You're sitting there eating your rash. He's just giving you death glare and then you see vibrating through there, pain begins to come and in you there you see him like snort as blood comes out of his mouth. He flicks his head and he looks back towards something you can't see. Yeah, Alistair's gonna kind of pop up and sort of toot a little about this wall here. We'll see. Yep. Okay.
You can see they're out of phase, but spiders and ghoul things beginning to on the other side of that wall from you that are moving towards this spot. What would you like to try to do? I have to say your decor is kind of bleak. And he's going to pull out a piece of chalk that he got from one of the kids. And he's going to start trying to draw like a unicorn.
What the f- Okay, um, you can give me a performance or a sleight of hand. Ooh, sleight of hand. Psychological warfare in the metaphysical dimension, dude. I will let you, real quick, once you do this, I will also let you do an insight check on this. Okay. Are you adding your d10s? Yeah. Okay. Sleight of hand. 25. Okay, give me the insight. 10.
Okay, as you do this, you do have a bit of a... You can read some of the words that are on the walls, some of the spell work, and though you're not really up on all this magic, you're like, well, I think that unicorn foot would go here, I think this one would go there. As you do, the magic begins to fluctuate. I need a wisdom saving throw.
Yo. Net 20 incoming. Start summoning unicorns instead of spiders and imps. Pink fluffy unicorns dancing on rainbow. It's a magical Leoparada. Okay. So, with your high talent of drawing with chalk, you...
do alter the spell folder. And as you do, there is a psychic attack. As it hits you, and you grab your head, hold your head for a second, and you come back down, as you look, the cord that you had partially pulled out is becoming more steady attached to you. However,
There is a weird flash and a burning sensation around you in the... in the... in the... aspects. And that part of the wall that you were seeing sort of like snap shut. You have altered the ability for that side of the room's reinforcement. So... okay. Um... However, as that happens, you're going to feel...
the Yankee King as he tries to jerk you away. So I need that con save. That's great! Oh man. 26. Wait. 28. Let's go. Okay. Let's go. So do you guys remember, uh, okay. You had a 28? I think so. Let me add it again. Well, it's a 10 plus a 13. It's 29 plus 2 minus 3. Yeah. Okay.
Was that 19? Oh hell, I thought it was 13. Okay. So at this moment as he yanks, do you wish to try to let him pull? Taking damage now is your new lead. It's at 4. Or do you want to use this opportunity to hurt him? I think we'll go for hurting him this time. Oh. I need that DT. Nuke this man. 10. Holy fucking gold.
Yo, that's my favorite rabbit of all time right there. Okay, so. You just psychologically send a dig pig. From your guys' point of view, the demons spawn in, things are happening. All of a sudden, there is like a magical explosion on the wall. And as one of the...
Demon small creatures is coming through and gets severed in half and half of it falls in and it's just closed. And at that sensation, Demon looks over there, makes a quick motion, and then he takes, um, okay, so he leans over, buckles over in half, and vomits blood. Oh! Eww! Um. I was about to vomit on my jades.
Aw man, not on the... These are fresh bro, come on! So, I'll give anyone a free on sight thing once you're on this. Oh hell yeah! Always! I'm good at those! 30, 20, no just kidding, 17. 7. 7. Uh, 21. I got excited and almost forgot to do the minus 3. Zach, with you being closer to this, you saw the four crits land.
Nothing happened. I mean, he did damage. He did 16. Yes. Alistair did more damage than that's fair. That's what fucking goes with it. Alistair, you do a ratio of four times the amount of damage that you roll in that round. Roach is brain streaming every fucked up thought he can think about while annoying the crap out of him.
With a 10 on that dice and the fact that you... He bobs against hearts. So remember the rule about crits? If it's 10 over a crit, you were 19 over his save. That was a devastating roll. Would we say he's bloodied yet? You gotta remind me what that is. Approximately half.
Of course. Oh, holy shit! That 10 was huge! I'm just imagining, coughing baby, nuclear bomb, but it's the opposite of what you would expect. The rabbits, the nuclear bomb, the 40-foot demon is the coughing baby. So, Justicar is going to go at it. He has advantage. That is a crit.
On the dice. That is a miss. That is one crit and two misses. With three dice. That's rough. So, crit. Unlimited crits. But no crits.
Let's roll it. That's not even like a huge by-taste, but that's like no low-quill-y, no low-quill-y space. I don't know why. It's because it got posted everywhere. Yeah. I'd rather have games. 15 is 30, which is doubled again to 60 points of damage on the quill. But you'd rather have games. But no games. Unlimited games. But no games. Alright. Um, has to make the deck sick.
That is a natural 1. So as you are standing there, he comes in and does the grab. You want to sacrifice yourself? He grabs... Not now! I got 30 hit points! He grabs the Azamir and begins to lift him up. Alright. Do you have your reaction correct? I'm using my Holy Avenger. You do have a reaction. I have a reaction so I can make an attack. Do you have a shotgun? Kidding.
Holy Avenger? I'm just going to say I'll let him try first. Or do you want to not do this and let someone else do it? You just have to get 30 points of damage on a hit, you get the 2d8. Because I'm not melee range. You are on the ground with a spider biting you. Now... Because he does have the Holy Avenger for this. If you can hit... I don't think I'll do anything at range, so I'm going to save my reaction. Precision Strike for advantage? Yep.
It's a 15 on the first. Plus 9. It's a 24 on the first. 15 for... 15 plus 9? 24. 24 on both? No, 24 is the 1. Alistair, roll me a luck. Because you're a one-shot. But the amount of damage he did, I want to save it. Yes!
What the hell are you rolling over there? I'm in his head. He's like, I'm in your head! I'm in your head! Okay, moving forward, guys.
is AC is 21 instead of 25. You rolled a d4 and I saw the 4 and I'm like, oh, hell yeah! Okay, so that's a hit. That's a hit. Okay, I'm just making sure to mark that down. That is a hit. That's a hit. That's honestly huge because that's more damage. Now, does my holy weapon apply to my bow as well, or is it only to my axe? It is to all your guys' weapons. That's even fucking better. So that's... Hey!
Let's let's let's do some math on that. That's a d10 So it's gonna be 2d8 a d10 and then 2d8 So 2d10 radiant 2d8 radiant plus a... Those are d10s Oh I only do 1d10 Oh but 2d10 radiant yeah Okay yeah that's what you were doing 3d10 and 2d8
Which? 5, 8, 8, so 16, 16 plus 5 is 21. 21 plus 7. So that's 28. And then here's the 2d8s. Where'd my other d8 go? Where'd it go? It's so weird. Where'd the fuck did it go? Here's a d8. Just take that one. I need it back though.
6 and 3, so 9. That is 30, right? Plus your modifier. Well, wouldn't it be time to make... Wait, wait. What did we say was... We're at 28 plus 3 is 31, is 39, plus 7, so 46? You'd already added the 7. It already added the 7? Okay. There is no rating. So, straight up, 39 doubled to 78.
Yeah, I think that... Do I break his arm at that point? No. It'll hurt. 78 points of damage. Specifically, put it right on the elbow. So as you go in with that, as he's lifting up, he drops dead. And he comes coming down. He falls down to the ground. And we'll see.
He's got a superhero landing. He lands on his feet because he's an azimuth with wings. That's what I'm talking about. Granted he does have a broken wing with that nasty one. And I'm weird. Okay. That's what we needed baby. Let's go. Okay next is Rurik who has the guy on top of him. He is going to make an attack. That is a crit.
And so that's gonna kill her. He's going to rise to his feet as he throws the spider off and step up to this guy and take a swing. That is a natural 20 on the dice.
Fucking go I don't think he I think he's rolling like the loaded dice that ones run through five is ones and then 16 through 20 is 20s He's just flipping a coin he's not even rolling a die
Success or failure? That is 25 points. You know what? Which is double. He's rolling like Katie right now. And I do not approve of this message. Which is double. I'm about to do a coin flip. Which is 100 points of damage. That sucker is gone. Yay. Let's go. Bye, motherfucker. He's actually living in a great town.
Ogre 3, before you even have to do it, is... Okay, next Ogre. He is going to come in. You are prone on the ground. I am. And he is going to make a couple attacks at you with advantage. Okay. That is a 5 on the die, and an 18 will miss. I will miss. I'm going to be surprised. Will too.
Surprise! He missed! Dude, he's got a pretty dang good bonus to this. He's... and he whooped him. I was gonna say, I've made all my con saves for damage and I'm still at 21 AC. Havoc is going to stand up and hit this guy. One attack. Missing a hit. Missing it. Six plus...
15 doubles is 26 plus 6. Yep, he kills it. Next in initiative is Penelope. Penelope is going to shoot the one right next to her. And you, sir. So that will be a miss and a miss. Apparently she can only shoot far away. Which brings us to the imps. Which, unlike the other rounds, we will be short.
four of them. So if you guys will just put four dead creatures on top of the stuff by you guys on the side as Alistair has closed the other. That's a lot of little guys. I'm just a little guy. Okay, two of them are going to... One is going to come up here and the other is going to come up here and they're both going to start long casts. This one is going to fly down to Penelope.
This one is gonna come down. Voss, Voss! The dice tell their own story. It's three and a four. Consecutive misses on both of those. Next initiative is the one... Okay, so the one flying up by your drone is going to try to... Does a 16 hit it? I don't think that is. It's a C. Okay.
It will take four points of damage. However, it is now grappled and it is riding on top of it. Kind of grab on top of it. Okay. It's rolled up on top, so that's its position. For sake of this, if you want to go anywhere besides straight down, it's going to be double movement. Because you've got someone on your back. And you zap. You can't zap it on top of you. Okay. That's the only one left. Okay.
Next initiative is Reggie. Reggie's gonna lay his hand back and you keep them and heal you. You will take 16 points. You will also give Jefferson a Bard Conspiration again. Another one? Because you used yours, right? Oh, you haven't? I haven't.
And they don't really stack so... Yeah I can't, I thought you... Okay. Um, who's after them? I haven't had to. Uh, he'll give it to... Ho. Ho? Give it to the Ho. That's Jose, Jose, Jose. That's a d8? Yeah. Okay. This is so bad. Deverson, you are on the ground with a spider trying to eat you and the guy's stopping you. That is true. Um, I'm going to stand up, use up my movement. Okay.
Let me out of your pincers, bro. I would technically have advantage on either of these guys, right? Yeah, I mean, you're grappled, but that doesn't change anything. Oh, am I grappled? Yeah, in his teeth. Okay. I will make my first swing down at the spider. Okay. I will be splitting my attacks. Gotcha. So, first attack towards the spider. That's not that great. 16 to hit? 16. On the spider? Yes, it does hit. Does hit. Okay, I will roll that damage real quick.
Remember I was able to one shot these guys fairly well, so let's see if we can just do that without dumping any resources. Yeah, their AC is 15, same as the... Don't forget your Radiant. I have not. So that's 14 Radiant, 18, 27 Plasma. So 45, that's a total? Yeah, you do too. Okay. No longer grappled, the second attack from the flurry is going to go towards the ogre.
That's bad. That's a 15. That is a miss. Okay. Bonus action, Back Swing. This attack will be at advantage. Yes. Because I can only do the flurry once per turn. That's a 28 to hit. That is a crit because you're 10 over his AC. Oh, hell yeah. If that's the case, I will dump a...
Intensified Strike, and I'm going to add 2d6 of the Weapons Damage type, so this will be an extra 2d6 Plasma. Okay. 2d6 Plasma. Ooh, and that's almost max on the Radiant. That's a 1 on the d12 and a 5. Okay, so that's 30 Radiant, already doubled. And then 5, 9, 12, 21. So, the...
The radiant, so that was a crit. So the radiant, I doubled it to 15. Oh, and then we need to double this again. Yeah, so that's going to be 60 radiant then. And then 42. Yeah, I forgot it was a crit. My apologies. I also forgot it was a crit. I was like, you should have just, yeah, you crit this deal. Was it demon or spider? Both. Both. Both. Both. Both. Both.
I mean the holy weapon is making it possible for us to clear the dags at a pretty damn good pace. Um, where the hell is that? Okay, so yeah, he is going to because he... I'm coming for that eight foot penis. Because he is not summoning people in from that side, he now has a...
layer action available. He is going to raise his hands up here. Actually, this is... It's a whirlwind. Okay, this is where he gets funny. So he's going to raise his hands up here, and as he's going to do this, he is going to cast a spell. Now, this key. I am going... This is always so funny. Let's figure this out.
A layered action typically can't be counterspelled. But he's a demon. And I just rolled... Yeah! Okay, the Justicar is going to counterspell. Let's go! Because Justicars can do shit that makes sense. Oh hell yeah. Because the rules really suck on some things. You know? They don't logically exist. Oh, he's doing a layer action. I have a counterspell! It's a magical effect.
So, the Justicar counterspells his fireball. Yeah! Hell yeah. This brings us to... How are you guys doing on that old... This guy, he's gonna step up and he's going to shoot that guy. My phone's a little goopy. That is a miss. The other guy is...
My turn? Jose! Son of a bitch. Uh, you. What am I doing? It's your turn. Oh, okay. So... For some reason... I don't think it's your cord. I think it's my plug. This is an older phone. It's not that it's not a Type-C. It's that it's got a very particular way it needs to be received. Literally only one of my chargers at home works on it. So, I'm not particularly surprised that it didn't.
What you got? I think I'm going to jump down and run over towards the yellow eagle so we'll lost by... 15, 20, 25, 30, 35 and then I'm going to have my drone come straight down so that you have all four there and spin just a little bit and I'm going to shotgun blast that way. It's positioning because of the cone.
You're gonna get... Should be two at disadvantage, two at standard, I think. Yeah. And I think I'm perfectly positioned in between allies, so it should only hit those four guys. It's close. We'll do a two hit. Oh, good. Who do you hit? One of them makes it. One of them fails. The other two fail. So, yeah.
One of them will... Your shotgun still has radiance, so... Yeah, it's still doing radiance too. So, just roll your normal damage. Tell me where you're at. Just regular damage? First. I just wanted... 20 regular damage. No, 27 regular damage. Okay. 27 force. Absolute Venom on radiant. I rolled two ones, so that'll be four radiant damage. Okay, so four radiant damage plus...
27. So 31 total damage. 31 total damage. So the two, the three that failed are dead. Yeah. Do they have 30 health? Yeah. Yeah. Alright, so that was the one on the drone, one that failed. Yes. Yeah. It is going to turn and attempt to zap the close guy over there. Yo, he's doing more?
I was like, yo, keep doing that. You might want to stun the guy that's ritual passing. Right, but I think I don't have the movement because he had to come down to get it off of him. Oh, fuck. And now I can't see because I'm below the bookshelves. Yeah, you've only got one shot. Yeah, yeah. What's the save? I'm just going to shoot the guy right beside him. You're doing damage or stun? Stun.
He doesn't have a damaging thing, he just has stun. He has 18 on the die. 18, okay. He's good then. Okay, he is not stunned. That is your turn, sir? Yep. So I don't have anything bonus action that I need to do right now. Because I didn't use my Fisticuffs, and I don't really need a bunch of health. I could use a Tiny Gap, but eh. I still got all that Temp HP, so. Alright, two spiders spawn in.
This little buddy has his HP back. We're just gonna skitter it over to here. And this one is going to go up the wall instead of attacking. I don't like that. I need... Alright, I need strength saves as it shoots a web out to tangle you sir, your drone, you yourself. It'll be them, them.
And those guys. Am I just out of it? You're just out of it. That's a strength. Yeah, strength. 19. You're good. Awesome, them both made it. Little guy fails. 15. 15. You are tangled in this web. You are restrained. 21. You reroll it? Or was that the drone? The bardic inspiration.
You pass. Yeah, how's the drone? Probably getting tangled. It has a plus zero. It's a 16. So I have to roll a 16. And I rolled a 3. Okay, with that, Spider is going to make its attack on the Jester part of the Logitech. He must make the next move. He will burn you.
I'm a little worried about the little two-face homies over there. The ritualists? Yeah, I can't really get to them. I'll have one on my turn. I am curious what they're doing, but I don't really want to see what they're doing either. Yeah, that missed. And he hit it. Nice. Okay. That is the Spiders. Next goes the guy who's Tangled. He will try to break free, and that is another failure. He's still Tangled.
Um, but follow me. It is your turn, sir. I'm gonna walk up to the... one of the fellas doing the spellcasting. Alright, now he is up high, so you'd have to cl- uh, you have the movement, you'd have to climb up to him. Or shoot him with your bow. He's about 20 feet up. Shiza. Um... Shiza? I mean, kids these days, such short legs. For real?
Do I have enough movement to be able to get up to him? You have... What is your movement? My movement is 25. Because you had to step up. You are about 20. Climbing takes double, so you need 40 feet to climb up to him. Can I do an athletics check? You don't want to shoot him? The bow? The holy bender? Yeah, I'll just... Can I take back my movement? Yeah, you can take your movement, yeah. That's not where I'm meant to roll. Dirty 20. And that will hit him. Cool.
Alright, dirty 20, so that's gonna be a 10 plus two more d10s. Four, two, one. You have savage, right? Yeah, I do. Uh, yeah, I'll read it. I'll read it. Four, three, two, fuck. Four, three, two. I've got some, but it's fine. Four, three, two, seven, two, nine, ten.
11 plus 7 is 18. 18 doubled because it's all radiant. 18 doubled for... 36. Oh, 36. You have killed that one. Oh my god, that took fucking everything. Jesus. I spiked his dragon. Tell some stories, share some guides.
I will be able to... Do I get to use... No, it's right to the shop. So... That's one of the quotes in our in-person campaign. Oh, you know what? Our paladin was like, we should go to the tavern, you know, tell some stories, share some guys. Hey, yo! I'm gonna go back over here and get this guy.
One of my other favorites. Josh, it's a black dragon. It doesn't have as much speed. Nope, that's a black dragon. Oh, okay. Yeah, I'm going to never get one. Okay, bonus action with Blake. I'll be honest. The last, like, three months, we've had, like, a baby once a month. Because we've just been so busy. So, like, we're going to get together. It's just, like, hectic for, like, two hours. Like, there's nothing against that. Like, it's almost as bad as the online game. I can't remember. Oh, it's six players. Oh, it's six players instead of five.
At least it's a person. So it's like two people. What's the wording on your medallion? I'm not sure if you've seen it. A medallion of Hestia. So Hestia's blessing, proficiency, bonus times day, change a 1 into a 20. Back swing when you make the action, attack action, you can use your bonus action to make an additional attack. But you did a bow shot, so yeah. Okay, so.
Yeah, all right you can move up and to give them flanking on their attacks against me Surge bigger never mind. Oh bonus action surge of vigor. Yes. I'm so glad yeah Go for it. Oh
Miss. Not even bottom. Three and a two. That's rough. Okay. Two guys there. One is going to go. He finally hits one. Six plus... Boom. The guy was at 15 health. So that is just enough to kill the imp. Alright, the one next to the lion goes down.
And this guy is going to... Somebody has to roll something for me. Just roll a d20. A d20? Nat 20! The only good thing I've rolled all night. And it might not be for a good thing at all. So all 20 members of the other party are already dead. We're going to have to go kill the other demon after this. The guy is smart enough not to shoot the demon with me.
Oh, okay. The big one? Yeah, he was gonna shoot the big guy. So instead he'll take his bow and try to shoot the guy who... Casting. ...who you missed. He critted! Let's go! Finally! This guy hasn't done anything at all. Okay, Grail is just radiant. Devil is 18.
Doubled again is 32. That will kill him without anything else. Guy in the middle, everybody down there, that guy's dead. The demon with the skeleton backpack? Yeah. That's actually like a sick little demon. Damn. Okay, there is one imp left for one guy casting. Yep. It is... Hey, it's somebody else! Hello. Okay.
That is a good answer. Instead of calling in one big guy, you still get these guys instead of a giant guy. Okay. Good news? Yes, because the big guy has more than 60. Here we go guys. I'd win. Just crit him, lol. Just crit bro. Just crit bro. It's not that hard. Can you take a werewolf? I technically do have an extended crit range, but I haven't rolled one yet. Oh.
Okay, uh, somebody. A d6. Not me. I'll do it. Three. Three. Three tree city. All right. Alistair. Chang gang. Okay, give me an insight. Let's see if you get this right. Beautiful. You know he is hurt very bad. Put me in coach. Give me a history check real quick.
Let's go tie this in. This is on your ability to pull up and remember the language in which you've played so far. You don't... you can't remember. You've got a lot of pressure, a lot of things going on. You do know you've hurt him a lot. You know that you're connected. You lost the initial duel for dominance over this. So, I'm going to throw this out to Aleister.
He has hurt a lot. You can try to hurt him more. Engage him directly if you wanted. But the tether will still be in place. You do not know if killing him will sever the tether. Because killing a demon sends them back unless they are wiped. So you still might be tied to him. You don't know because the justicars fight. That could be final death. What if you killed him?
is that final death threat? You don't know these things, but he is... He could die this week. Do you wish to try to remove connection completely this turn? Come what might be, knowing that to do so will be very probably damaging to you. Do something to help kill him, hoping that he is knocked out permanently from someone else's actions or group. Alistair gets the final kill, and then...
As the demon falls, we turn around to see Alistair now 40 feet tall. Damn, that's a big rabbit. Makes two for months. He really is the Messiah. I'm not the Messiah. That's what the Messiah would say. He is the Messiah. What's Alistair doing? I think Alistair... I think he's going to try to break the door. Okay.
Do you want to just grab it? We've got a couple options. You can try to piss him off to make him unique again and see if you can get his strength to do it. Or you can grab it yourself and roll a con save and try to hand a athletics to see if you can pull it. I think the play here is Alistair says something. I love interior decorating.
He's going to basically dash as far as he can towards the other one. I'm giving me a persuasion or intimidation check. It's a five. You run past. He looks at you and runs. I think I will fall for that again. He's going to look at you and go. He's going to reach down and he's going to grab the cord. But instead of yanking it, he's going to pull.
He's going to overload! Give me a sanity check. I'm blooding to you. You suddenly feel very stiff, like you can't move. Is that a nat 20? That's a nat 20. Plus five. Minus... Okay. I think those two over there are stealing all the nat 20 mojo from the rest of the table. I think that's funny in only a couple things. I've nat 20'd once. I haven't yet. I've gotten it.
Welcome to the last two sessions of combat for me! You know how many rolls triple advantage and I can't get a 17, 18, 19, or 20? To be entirely honest, I haven't done anything too crazy either. I'm just consistently dealing damage as the DM. Alright. As this power begins to come down, you have two choices. You can redirect it back towards him with that sanity check. This will damage him.
Or you can risk it all on Arcana to use his power to sever the connection. However, if you fail, you will take the damage. Okay. That is 45 points of damage. Sit back to him. Roll me that d10. Dang. Okay. Mediocre. Mediocre!
Still probably better than any of our hits though. Oh, well I haven't even hit... I haven't hit any. I've been stuck in fucking Goblin and Spider Alley over on the right. I was, but he pulled me out of that. I've been doing good against the Mimps. But that's about it. There's only a few million more that could come through that door here. With a... Heterious War here.
goes over, bends over, and as he vomits blood again, as he kind of stands up, he looks at you. And there is a flicker of anger, I mean, fury in there, but there's just a hint of fear in his eyes as he looks at you. You might be a true death ending, my friend. And at this moment, the Justicar's turn. He's Justicar. Is he, though? Probably.
He's going to... He is going to move as he does... That's not going to move. I forgot. He's got that reach. He's going to move to this position. And he is going to activate a... Let me see here. How dare he have a thingamabobber. It is...
Okay, I don't see the name in my notes, but it's basically you know how in they like Hadouken the straight line fire line attack I guess it almost be like chain lightning just penetrating. Well, just like the lightning. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, okay. That's probably why I didn't write the name down, but it's been transmuted to radiant damage. So, come on.
He is going to blow one of his specialties and make them roll these with disadvantage. Which is a good thing. That is a good thing. What? It's going to miss you. And with that disadvantage, all three demons finish.
Let's fucking go! I'm imagining it's a copy of All We Want right now. It is 8d10 radiant damage. Lick my man some nutsack and call him Jeffrey, bro. What the hell? 34 doubled. 68 to 68. The two of them are down. And that guy's 68. Mark that. Put me in coach. Get me in there. Put me in there.
Guys, I will wait for Alistair to come back. Demon goes next. As that lightning rips through the two next to him, they just disintegrate and blow up. Um... It's random body part. Jack. Yo. Give me an insight on this attack. You have advantage because you fought demons. Oh, yay! Thank god! Fuck. Seventeen.
With a 17, you know that the... Oh, that's huge. So it's a radiant disintegrate. Beam. I'll make that call. So... I won't be seeing any more of those two. With his attack, disintegrate. The lesser demons, this is something he knew. The lesser demons that were there were the ogres. They are permanent. Point of reference.
And where you are at, as you send that back, that damage, for a brief moment, reality cracks. And you get a glimpse. Up to this point, everyone was exactly where they were the whole time, except for the demons. Where you are now, you see everyone else around you in that moment as it flickers. As the pure, divine energy channeled through that lightning blast.
obliterates the demon in front of you. More damage than required to kill him. And you have defeated the demon. However, as you begin to come back to yourself and as it disintegrated, as you are fading back into reality, as everything is fading, you watch the cord begin to shrink in size. But as you are getting closer, give me a perception or insight. Perception.
D10? D7? You see it coming down and you're like, it appears to be fading. And as you come back into reality, the last thing you see is it's the size of your finger. It's not gone though! It's just flaccid right now. Has anything happened to the little demon there or the spider? Next initiative is Rurik. He's going to turn and look that way.
He is going to pull out a Mark III rifle and make a series of shots at the enemy. Being an old guy who has weapons, he's not a really good shot, but he finally hits him third. Is that Steli a little whippersnapper? Not actually. Hell yeah. That is not enough to kill him. Does that have radium?
That was with Radiant. He rolled a 1 on the damage dice. He is going to... He is going to run. Hopping down. Here. Action down. He is going to throw his weapon at the guy doing that. Oh, I need to do a concentration check for Liam. He made it. Alright. Throw. Good at this. With disadvantage, he hits him with his throw.
Don't teleport. Witch radiant damage is 14 plus... that's 21. He disrupts the guy's casting of fireball and kills him. Yee-haw! What's that? Not bleached. Let's see. Penelope is going to take two shots at the spider and she's gonna miss both. She is then going to have to reload the Grevolver. Who's next?
Reggie. Reggie is going to just hit him with cutting words. That is a failure. Talk some bad shit. Damn, Reggie. You caught yourself a spider. You don't have enough legs for that. Oh, your mistress would be so upset if she knew you were hanging out with a demon instead of her. You broke her heart. Um, uh, Jefferson, do you need a bardic?
So I can use mine. Okay. Let's hang on to it. Jefferson, it is your turn. Is it just the spider up there? Yep. I mean, I don't really have anything great to do. I guess I'll bonus action use my second wind to regain some hit points real quick. Do you want to shoot the guy? I'll regain seven hit points. I mean, I'll throw something his way.
I don't really have another good action to take. I guess I'll just wind up and I'll throw a javelin at him. I'll probably move closer so that I get within effective distance. How high up is he right now? About 30 feet. About 30 feet? Okay. This will be a disadvantage. Actually, no, it'll be a straight roll. That's probably a miss. 13 to hit with the javelin. So that's my turn.
Alright, uh... Oh, he can't move. He's gonna try to break free from his... Hey! He tears free! He's free. Free, free, free. What was that? Oh, sweat. Oh, sweat, oh, sweat, oh, sweat. I'm not a ranged character, but, uh, you're our best ranged character. And you were doing mental gymnastics this fight. We have a holy Avenger crossing. He's gonna hit him eventually. I'm...
Flabs off my drone. Okay. And then my drone's gonna fly up and... Just kind of get closer and then try and zap. Alright. That is... 14. 16. Falls to the ground. Thug zapper. Okay. He takes the ball, dude. I would have to shoot at disadvantage because my range is 12. The spider will... Okay. Um... You wanna... That's it?
Yeah, I don't have any bad assumptions or anything that I can do at that range anyways. Cause I'd have to climb up the bookcase and jump down the other side or a detour all the way around it. So even though I've got a lot of literature, it's not enough. No wait, it's Spider's turn. I need a moment. Spider's gonna get up. Spider is not happy. No shit. It is surrounded, basically. I wouldn't be happy if I was Spider.
Dude, I'd fucking kill myself if I was a spider. Spider's gonna step over to him. Uh, you're just bug. Um, and you should kill yourself. You don't even have to roll. I'll let you do it. It's a free action. Oh, that is great. With his dying breath, he crits it. Well, uh, Captain gets an F20 on his con save. No one has failed that save. Nope. No one's been poisoned.
It's not a standard poison effect. So he just takes the damage of... That is... 18 points of damage. Alright, now it is your turn, sir. Okay, I'm gonna shoot the little guy. He's on the ground. You want to run up and have advantage. You should have enough. Yeah, okay. I'm alright. Boop bug! Go to hardy jail. Because I rolled a 4 and he... Alright, that's a 8.
Two of those are doubled, so... True. 5 plus 10, 15. 15 plus 2, 17. 17 plus 7, 25. 25? 25 is exactly... Huge! That's not even including the extra radium on top of that. So 7 and 17 is 24.
if he got radiant and that stuff went to yeah he's got plenty to carry over with that we did it okay as that comes crashing to the ground um it finishes this the Justicar is going to turn and get good work and if he's going to start running back down the hallway to help you guys is the big demon still there or did he just kind of like
Fade away. He got disintegrated. No! My cock cloak! You yelled at us. He wanted that foreskin. I was gonna turn it into a fireproof cloak or something maybe. Okay, so that was the end of round four. Okay guys, so here is the result.
I'll note I'm following the Justicar. I'm probably not as quick as him. I'm also following. So the main thing with this battle was rolls for the other team. With him staying in his form like this, he has four within a minute resurrections. So since none of you died, he is able to use those four on the three people.
down on the other side before the timer runs out. So, when it's all said and done, you guys did not lose anyone besides the Hadozee. No casualties. None whatsoever.
None of our missions have had any casualties, right? Right? By the way, for a good two rounds I was at 6 HP. Yeah, so... I was above board on this, guys. So what would have happened is... If Alistair would not have done the big damage, and if he would not have done the extra radiant damage, I don't think he would have got the adds done fast enough. No.
But you kept pulling just enough off that beyond that one grip, if he would have got the bike, he would have lost concentration on that. Yeah. He was able to hold it on all the others. It's why I, for a moment, considered taking that hit for him. Yeah. So that he wouldn't lose his concentration. And you still had that option if it wasn't enough. So, as...
This begins to come to an end. The battle is put down. There are people who went down, but none of them are beyond rescue because of this. The battle kind of begins to come to an end, as it does. People run out. Things are happening. As a few of you follow the justicar out.
Some of the others are in there. Who stays in this room while the others follow the Justicar to the end? I follow the Justicar. So you two follow. Alistair, you just kind of come out. Yeah, I don't think I'm quite... There's literally burnt ground up to your feet. You took about a three sanity loss during this, didn't you? Because one from the last one. What is your sanity? I think it's eight.
Or a minus one. So as you're there, you've got right in front of you Reggie is standing there and his fur is actually been scorched. It's black. As he's standing there next to you, he looks at you and gives you a slight pat. Good to see you back. And he heads over and begins to try to help where he can with that. What? What was that?
We didn't even play with a Juan for that long. We only had like 14 sessions with that party. Jade. Jade's bard was Juan. Yeah. Nate, I'll just call you. As you're kind of looking there, there are a couple demons that are left on the ground that didn't get disintegrated. They're big. You can make Jack out of them.
but the big man you kind of notice Alistair is a little out of it he's got dried blood on his whiskers down the sides of his ears and you can see like he cried the blood like it came out of his eyes but he seems to be better than some of the other folks you've seen him worse and there's a lot of shock
Amongst the rest of the rabbit phone now red for the animal folks. They have never fought It's just there several of them are just like sitting there that they're the adrenaline has left and they're just not the shock the shock is saying the destruction and everything around them as They just kind of sit there in
Of people left in this room, comes walking over to you, nods at you, and goes, Well, we did pretty good here. Far better than I expected, to be completely honest. Aye, me too. I'm not exactly sure why, but something was hurting that demon really bad. That puking blood in the middle when no one touched him was pretty cool.
I don't know what that was. I've never seen nothing quite like that. Maybe that's why the justicar got close. Maybe he had an aura or something, but... It looks like he's chewing his... I don't know. He's got a decision to make. Kind of gestures with his head away from the others. I don't know what he's doing. He's going to put down that other demon no issue. Then they're going to have to clear the taint. That's going to be a long ritual. At least 12 to 18 hours long. So...
Do we stay here, travel back with the whole group, or do we head back now? Get a jump on things. The reason I'm asking you is how tired you guys are. I don't fancy staying here, but I ain't gonna go back alone. I like the smell here. I sleep back there. Or at least out under the stars. Wow. Smells like burnt ass hairs in here. He kind of looks down. I just about lost my chin hair when he did that last finisher.
It's close enough. Oh, hella close. He kind of grabs his beard and goes... I'm gonna see if there's anything interesting around here. Why don't you talk to the others and see about them and your friends want to get out of here. Or if you're gonna stay. There's a lot that's gonna be going down. Things need to be prepared and planned and I'd rather do it not with any ocean of bees, folks.
So it's me and Alistair and those two in the back of the other room? Yes. And the rest of the folks. So as you two run down the hall, you run past the reinforcement point where the folks were. And the Justicar has really put on some speed. And he's about a minute ahead of you by the time you get into the room. Damn! So...
Call that just a cartoon. Bolton! Yeah, he hit himself with haste and was using all three actions for damage. Damn. Or action. Second action. Yeah. Oh, second. Yeah. And, um... So, as you guys get into the room, um, you see, uh, multiple Inquisitors that are down, um, on the ground that are being patched up. There's about five of them that have, um...
One of them literally has a stone spear through his chest of the size of your arm. See? How? Another one, they have set him down and they've put his head next by his body. It got severed. But they've laid it up against it. And as you come in, this demon is not disintegrated.
and wiped, but it is down and dead. And as the two of you kind of look around, they're putting down the last of like the imps, just kind of finishing the ones that are wounded on the ground. And Lycus nods to you and kind of walks over and goes, it's pretty dicey there for a few minutes, but he kind of nods to you.
Uh, not as bad as some of the trenches. I kind of nod and say, was honestly expecting it to be quite a bit worse. For the Inquisition? Yes. That's a walk on the park for what we saw. He kind of shrugged me. I guess good equipment makes a difference. And training. And experience. And time. Preparation. Kind of looks at you. You can tell he wants to talk, but he kind of looks around and says,
And then he heads back over and starts... They're doing... They're sorcerers doing a little first aid. Yeah. And Amir is standing there and you have never seen such contrast in a person's face. There is an arrogant smugness to it.
But there's that you've seen officers when they they pulled something off good But there's almost the best way you can describe it is like sexual ecstasy from him achieving his goal On his face. It is eerily disturbing
Give me the right of execution. Hey, homie, I'm punching your chicken. I see your pants. They're wet right now. Calm down. He gets off on meaning terms, but that's his whole purpose. That and fighting traitors. Straight up chugged up mid-combat.
And as he's there, the justicar will walk up beside him, look, they'll say a few words and then he'll come over and begin to do the, I forget the sicker spell, but where you can bring someone back within the resurrection. Yeah, they left the 10 minute spells.
Ray's dead. And he begins to do that to those guys. And as that's going on, a few of the other soldiers kind of look around and it's a rough. It was a tough battle, but it was tougher than yours. Much tougher than yours. Did they have less people or was the people more poor? They didn't have Alistair went to it.
They didn't have a protagonist. That's why. They didn't have a chosen one. They didn't have the Messiah. He is the Messiah! So, shortly after he starts that, Amir comes up to you, Bartholomew, and smiles and goes, one step closer.
And he kinda nods at you and offers you the arm shake. I'll return it back. He grabs me with his... It's going to take us a while. We're going to have to set up the ritual purification. Feel free to, uh... If you wish to, participate or meditate with us, that would be great. But if you have other duties, we understand. I'll offer a bunch of prayers, but I think I should help with the...
preparing for the base. Yes, if news gets back of what happened to Hadozee here, it could get very interesting. I'm not sure what the Indians' plan is, but almost none of them came. And almost none of them that received firearms from us or yourselves, and from them, I should say, came either. So, who knows when we'll finally get back.
If worse comes to worse and they're playing us, make sure they don't activate their defenses on us. Oh, we're going to make sure, all right, that they do. Yeah. Glad you made it. And then he's going to walk back over to the center. Also, can I get a hue? So this room is a bit different.
This was the second room's kind of layout. Again, it had broken loose, but it was a much different set. And this one has more... If you want, do you want to look around the room a bit and see what you can glean? I will. Okay. You can give me an investigation or an arcana check. See which one. Investigation's the same. It doesn't matter.
19. Dang. So, as you're looking at the differences between the two rooms, as you walk around and you bend down and you take your hand and you run it through the weird goo and you bring it up, you look at it, this one broke free after the one in your room. You would guess this one might have only been free.
three or four days. So it was still caged when you came out of the tunnel. And then you know that much and then as you kind of walk around and you're looking at this process you go ahead to the other end and you walk up on the little staircase and you're looking there. You're not sure. 19 is very good but
When you look at the chains and you look at everything in here and the amount of corruption here, you don't know per se if this demon was even in this plane. You're not sure on that, but it's a little odd. The corruption, the levels of demonic here would have been higher if this had been here the whole time. Did the other one summon it? Was it using it for something or did something else happen? You don't really know.
But whatever happened here is about to be purified and the blight will be pushed out. Zach? Yes, sir? While you're in here and they're bussing around and you're watching the justicar do his work and put people back together, I mean, you've seen, you know it can be done, but even in your combat, seeing someone...
Burn the resources to bring someone back. That's like a colonel or a general and you weren't around them when they went down. You knew it happened. But in that war you had to be somebody or filthy rich. So you might have seen this happen once in your entire life. As that's going and you're watching you kind of look around the room.
And you feel the power in you beginning to calm that part of you. It's been more prescient as time has gone on, growing more and more since you've left the service and you've been in these places. But as you kind of walk over to the odd, churning purple liquid next to this on either side,
It has kind of an odd look, like the difference between a raw mana crystal and a processed one. And as you're looking at that mana crystal, that goop there, in there, it's different, it's not been infected. You feel a little tug in your throat from your own amulet. You feel like a presence is like beating up against your mind. It wouldn't take much to push it out. Mark two legs.
whatever this is, or do you want to keep your mind clear? So what exactly am I standing in front of? Okay, so on the map you can see, you can pick any of these, but this is like a liquid vat of, that is the same texture as between a refined ether crystal and a raw one. And it's like a thick liquid. Okay. So a thick liquid.
He's curious. Cautiously, whatever's tugging at his mind, he kind of opens up to. Okay, as you do, you hear that, you feel that presence of home in Hearth again. But it is not, it's a safe place, but it is not a peaceful place.
It's almost the best way I can describe it to you is you're in a place of home and something is threatening that home. But you're with those you trust. And as you're looking at that liquid, you hear a wisp of a voice say, Refined demon blood mixed with divine energy molded with the crystals. It's quite the cocktail. Extremely dangerous.
I do not know what you wish to believe or think of me. I owe you a debt. I can be with you and try to give you blessings, or I can repay you now. Jefferson kind of takes a moment and says, one who knows much about the mystical or gods, but from what I've seen, you're not the worst of what I've seen. I don't see a reason to be rid of you.
You've helped as much as I may not like some of your other servants. There's no comment on that. I'm laughing, not her. I know, I know, I know. And he's just like, if you're willing to stick around and help me, I'll do my best to... I mean, I ain't gonna be your servant to be pointed one way or another. But I feel like what you are and what I try to be aren't too far different from each other. You are... ...are all for your understanding of me.
What you have made and held together in your small group is, in many ways, a family. You take care of your own, as a mother would care for her children more than the needs. There is nothing wrong with that. You take care of your own first. And with that, she gives you one more word of not every child a mother raises is a good child.
Despite your actions, your teachings, sometimes they can be less straining. Other times, they were opening. And with that, the presence kind of falls away. I'll kind of take a second. Looking down at this liquid in front of me, does it look like it's going to incinerate me if I touch it? I'm not necessarily going to touch it, but I am thinking about drinking a health potion and trying to fill it with this stuff. It is bubbling magic.
interacting with you would be very interesting. It would be a constitution saving throw. Well, hell, I'm good at those. I know you are. So, that is, um, but, there will be some level of damage taken by interacting with it. That's cool. I'm gonna drink a health potion, one of my standards. I have two standards, so I'll go down to one. Action. Yeah, and I'll heal ten. Do you want me to roll?
Action you get a d. So I'll heal for that and then, you know, it's not huge, but it's a health potion. And I'll kind of kneel down and dip it in, try not to touch it too much, but just fill that up and then cork it. Give me a constitution saving throw. That's a 31. You fail. I got a bardic! Okay, DC was 45.
Okay, so you might want to use the partner. It lessens results. Okay, I'll roll the d8. Okay, it goes up to 24 or 34. 34. Yeah. Okay. As you dip it in there for a brief moment as it interacts with your skin, you have, it is grit your teeth, lock jaw pain.
And as you bring your hand out of it for a moment, all you see is your skeleton and all the skin and muscles being removed off your hand. And then as you bring it up, you watch it grow back. As you look at your hand there for a second. Like two fingers that were holding the bottle like... Uh, yeah. It wasn't even the ones that went in. Oh, shit.
The froth of it. My hand. Take it. And as you come back up, you watch your skin grow back. And as it does, with a 34, some of the nanites in your system that interacted with it were destroyed. Well, that's good, at least. So, roll me a d6. Oh my god, you're about to get upgraded to nanobots. One.
Okay. I'm having one skeleton hand. Cool. One skeleton hand, one normal hand. I take my strong hand. The nanites are enhanced from this interaction. You may pick one stat. I won. I'm at 29 for constitution. Is it going to make it 30? Well, 28, sorry. I'm at 28, so I wouldn't get an extra modifier.
Off of that. The only one I would get the modifier bonus in is Strength. Because I've already cut my Strength from the last time that was a problem. So I'll probably just dump it there to go back to plus 3. Okay. You with possession something insane. Huge. I'm just going to write down something insane. A bottle of Divine Namet. Tainted with demon. So.
As you're finished looking around, you see him kneel down and get up, kind of stand up, and then he's kind of looking at his hand, shaking. You kind of look around for the place as things are going on, and then is there anything else you guys want to do in this room? Work it. Put it in my back. Do I lose any health points? Not with 34. I'm huge.
I just lose half the skin on my hand for, you know, like two minutes. It grew back. It grew back. You know, there's this one time I lost all the skin on my hand. What happened? Oh, it grew back. So as about this time, is there anything anyone wants to do in either room before you begin to kind of regroup up?
I can't think so. I mean, I want to be very perceptive of the Inquisitors and how they're acting and everything. And, you know, if they go off for their own little meeting or something. Just trying to keep tabs on all of the big names. The Justicar goes back and sits at the crossroads of the place. And he goes into a meditative stance after blowing so much stuff.
in this fight. And as he does, the rest of the Inquisition and a number of the other people that are working with them, some of the military folks, they're going around and they're putting little artifacts like relics of divine gods and power throughout in some kind of system throughout the rest of the facility. A lot of them are beginning to be put on specifically on the
alter locations and things like that. With that being done, most of the animal folk are kind of gathering up and they're wanting to head back. We fought the demons, they want to leave. But there's some discussion. They're pretty beat up and tired. So the majority end up deciding they're going to take a long rest.
and do that. So, before they head back, you guys kind of meet up. You have a little bit of time after the battle and everything. Wow. Are you still sticking with the church or are you going to go back to the group or are you going to the animals because of the ones that you were interacting with because a couple of them were working with you to keep the Inquisition in the loop?
How are you going to handle this if you're not going to stay for the ritual? I think... I think I'm going to stay in the temple, actually. Okay. You'll stick there, stay, make sure it plays out, guard them whether it's their weakest. Yeah. Well, I'm a 6L, but don't worry about that.
Well, as you guys are there, during this, if you need, you've got potions and all kinds of stuff that they gave you because they opened up their stores to you. Oh, I forgot. Or if you take the rest, you can roll hit point dice if you stay there and rest. I'll just stay there and rest. Is it long rest or? Yeah, if you stay there, it'd be long rest. Okay.
As most of the animal folks are there, the military has to stay with them. Reggie kind of comes up to you and kind of nods to you and goes, Check on your boy Alistair. He's pretty messed up. Alright. You can see in his eyes something weird happened. I was thinking as much. Go ahead.
Felt the need to rush off, but yeah, once we calm down we'll do a brief. We'll figure something out. I don't know about you, but I'm afraid of the blight over this smell. Yeah, it's pretty nasty. Are you staying here in the night? We're gonna at least head out of the tunnel and talk out there. Better. Better company. I concur. We'll see. I need to chat with Rory to see what's going on. We might be heading back this evening. Get a jump start. So...
He's in bro
Burned hair. She's got shots, but you look she looks she looks like she's gone through but you look really bad Apparently if she is responding to you as a voice, you are there. She just locked up and started bleeding from every orifice in your face You know, your nose, your whiskers. Oh She gets out some water. She says, watch your face. You've got blood all over your face.
We made it out alright. She kinda looks around and steps where someone can't see her. How do you load this? She's gonna show you the pistol. I can't figure out how to load it. It helped, but I don't know how to load it. So she's like, that's the worst thing about these guns. Unlike any other. Don, man, you gotta take time to...
So she sits down and you start talking her through cleaning the gun and she's kind of fussing over you, wiping that, as you're showing that, wiping blood and passing you a strawberry every once in a while so that your fur is still red. Alright. I don't suppose you have any pride. You've got a bad anchor. The demon in me wants pie. Bench me, pie. Did somebody say strawberries?
Oh, would you like a few? I would love some. They're the baby ones that she hands you. The silver one, the size of a cow loaf. Ah, these are... Hands you two pounds, strawberry. Yeah, not quite as big as the other ones, but hey, just as sweet. Yes. And she kind of looks over at you and I'm glad that you're doing well too. Because I was worried there for a while. It was unlike anything I'd ever seen before.
Ah, it wasn't too bad. She looks at her back. First time will get you. Every time. Every time. First time will get you. Every time. She kind of nods. Works 60% of the time. Every time. So that's kind of the talk that's going on. Rurik is looking around in the other place. And I assume that you come back in. Yeah, I'll come back in. Then...
They're sitting right kind of there by the door eating giant strawberries. Hell yeah. I think I would wander over those bookcases and see if anything looks interesting coming from a monster hunter background. Okay. All right. Yeah. If anyone wants to give me any kind of investigation checks or anything in this room diluted before the church. Okay. So as...
Okay, I'll let you do that. You can do that, Rurik will do it. But as soon as the church comes in, if it's not out of sight, you're going to have to sleight of hand it, because this is all... they're confiscating everything they can get their hands on. Oh, that's a very good roll. He's a master looter. Yep. I mean, he does own an antique shop. And he is old enough that most of these might... he might be older than some of the stuff they're in. So close.
You still got that bar? Nah, I used it. 17. Yeah, 17. Has any investigation yet? Yeah. Yeah. All right, so as you're going through these, most of these just look like books now, but it's that weird stuff that he was looking at and stuff that Clayton was into. And as you're kind of going through, looking at them, I was like, I don't know, do you want to throw me in the bag of holding or are you just kind of looking through them?
I think if there's anything that looks like fancier, I would probably put that in real quick. All right. So I can't fit the whole case in the bag of holding. No. So I'd probably just be picking and choosing like a handful of random ones. And then if anything stood out specifically. Okay. So as you're going through, you're looking, you're going, you're looking for fancy.
or name your books. So I'm looking for anything that would strike me from a Monster Hunter's background. Okay, that's different. You're grabbing shiny, but you're looking... I'm grabbing shiny. I'm specifically looking for anything that Monster Hunter background would call to me. The shiny is kind of a secondary thing. Okay, as you're going through, you do come across a leather book, but it is in...
Rough leather. So immediately here you go. This is a homemade one. So you grab it and as you pull it out, the first thing you notice is it is not an Elvish. What languages do you speak? Common, deep speech, Elvish, Janya. Hell yeah! Why does Ro have deep speech? That's what I'm asking!
That's really what I'm asking! Good choice, but also... It's from my Monster Hunter. That's why. Yeah. I was like, I had a reason for taking it. I don't remember what it is at this point, but I had a reason. As you open it up, it is a treatise on monsters and flora in what is now called the Upside Down, which used to be called the Underdark. Okay.
Okay. And as you're looking at that, give me a luck check. 10. Really good at rolling straight in the middle of my luck checks. I haven't rolled good or bad on them. You notice that you, you, you know, you've seen, you've gone through a few lucks. You're not a big reader, but when practical, you use that. Jose's a big reader.
Well, yeah, he's big in grades. Bigger than most. I'm a pretty big reader. I only read about one book a year, but I'm a pretty big reader. And as you're looking at it, you do find an interesting section in there where some pages have been removed. You know something was in there, but it doesn't really make, you know, like...
These were torn. These weren't... somebody tore these out. It looks dope. But that's what you believe from that. Rurik comes walking up to next to you and goes, I put that away quick. And Church Boys show up and kind of nods and goes, oh. Grabs a book, pulls it out, flips it open, shakes it, and it was cut out and there's another book that falls in his hand. Tucks it in his shirt pocket and goes...
And that's about the time that Zach and you head back over to the straw place as the church people come in and begin to look around and start gathering, piling stuff up in places, putting down different things. Was I able to find any fancy looking ones to kind of just sweep in there?
Yeah, you found like three of them. That was what that roll was on. You found some pretty... They're in that elven and they've got like inlay of like silver inlay on the outside. They're the prettiest books. Okay. Sweet. So... As that happens, you guys... I don't know about y'all, but I think I'd rather get some fresh air. Even the blight's better than this bloody place. I agree.
So with that, your group kind of gets up and begins to head out. And as they walk past you on the way out, Rurik does kind of look at you. And as you guys make eye contact, he's not terribly angry. He's not resentful. It's more of a weary sadness when he looks at you. That disappointment.
And... I'm not bad. I'm just disappointed. And as he kind of walks past, I think you would know that he knows about your confession. Yeah. You hadn't been told that, but it would go to reason. So, why don't you give me a history check while you're thinking about this. Okay. So, even though you look at him and he goes away, you're tired, you're hurt.
You're drinking the potion, you're staying around here. It doesn't occur to you to check on the ring. Yep. Because it's secure. And as they head out, you guys get to the outside of the tunnel. And it is easier for you. The first thing Rurik looks at you guys and your group. He reaches into his little belt and he pulls out a ring. And it has a little... It's a gaudy ring.
It has like a dove on it. And he just kind of turns it. As he does, there's this as silence goes out around you guys, around your group, and around the animal folk. And he goes, we have two very simple choices. One, we go back before everything that the keeper kept away comes here. He goes, or two,
We stay with them and have numbers when we do prefer. Almost want to see if we can convince some of the other animal folk to leave today with us. I'd rather get out of here and get a head start before anybody else is following. There's one more aspect then. I have two things. Do we go straight back or do we go to the temple where I left supplies and I had a teleport? What about you?
I thought he had removed all that to the edge for the rabbit folk. So I said I did. Son, they didn't take down the portal. It's unguided at the moment. We could go and get out. We could get down. But between you and me, I need to get out of here one way or the other. I can go with the rabbit folk. Or I could. Do you think I am necessary?
for the success of this. Maybe if they both- one of them have died, but I need to get back to the business that matters. I know. If you feel the need to stop in the temple, we can take off tonight and head that way, say we're heading back to the trail. We'll still be ahead of them by the time they leave. That means none of the animals will come with us, it's just us. I know. I think they'll be fine. I think they'll be alright. I- I don't want to worry about us, but...
You have a friend in there, don't you? I don't know how much we can call it a friend anymore. How much can you call the... ...Hadozee traitors? It's blood magic. It's mind magic. It's...something that the evil's not able to defeat. Who knows if it was willing. Well, I didn't like him much before the spider either, so... Yeah, he was a bit of a weird one. I mean, he was one of ours, but... Yes.
I understand that. Spider got to him, whether it was willing or slowly degrading him. This is your only chance. He will not live, one of it, when they stop that. They will kill him if he is not already dead. I have a feeling he wouldn't leave even if we asked him to. I mean, we can try. I'm willing to try, but... You think they'd let you in the temple without doing the entire trial again?
You don't like the Emissary, would they attack you straight up? I think it's more of a risk than what it's worth. I agree. I mean, he does have something of ours. He can always come and collect it when he's dead. We can try to, if everything goes well. If it doesn't go well, then we're not going to be much around to care, are we? I mean, fair. I mean, half of the other half of it's still in the banks. Which I...
Because of a certain individuals testimony, I'm going to be in a legal battle over it. I know. Another reason I need to get out of here before every asset is seized. For the time being, I would not expect to have access to those funds for the next year. Well, hell, we went from rich to poor. It don't matter. Maybe stop by on your way back to the city and get some crystals and stick them in your bag.
Because if their spell goes off there won't be any crystals around here. The man with one eye is king and the man with the blind. Yep. I was gonna see how much we could collect on our way back through and just see what we can hoard. Even if this goes well, there's going to be issues with as many of your people that are leaving. Their finances are going to be enough to get them through, but we're not going to get them all through.
than likely before the ritual starts. And if they're on this side when it ends, and even if we are successful, there's no crystals to power them for. Whoever's on that side and has already been on that side by the time we get there will be... They will be on Unity. At least they're in the guild lands. But that will have its own complications because they will have small amounts of crystals to get started in a world that they don't understand.
It might be beneficial for someone to go through on before the end. There's another option Messiah. He kind of smiles at you. Alistair gives him like a weird look, kind of chuckle. I know he looks down at your chest. You have more than one problem. And he snaps. And there's a brief flick of light. And there is a small...
Invisible tether going somewhere from out of your chest. I lost you. Give me a perception check when he does that. I don't know if anyone else wants to. That's fine too. Try a normal one. You're not there. Oh, yeah, that's right. Just a normal one. Only 14. So, Alistair. 16. Not hitting the perception.
Anything related to demons or demonology, you get an extra detail. You got a 13 out of 16. I got a 14. 14. 16. There's one about the size of his pinky coming from his chest. No one else thought. Or the magic fades. And it's just us three and Bert. Now, sir. What's that coming out your chest? It's not there now.
You said what? Hair, I think. Oh, is that what it's called? No, I mean the little wire. It was there for a moment. I swear it was. Entirely sure. Curiosity almost got the better of me. It is, uh... If well executed, it's a path of power. If poorly executed, it's your existence. Snuck up. Let's, uh... My spell's about to end. He turns and he goes down.
Let us prepare to move. So, as you guys talk to the others, let them know you're headed out, most of the animal folk are going to stay, take a long rest, and leave after that. They don't want to stay too much longer, and it's going to take approximately a day for the church to finish their ritual. Okay. So, as you guys move out, we're going to turn...
to our glory. As you are sitting there in this place, this is very familiar to you. The fact that there was almost no casualties is important. Especially compared to the ones you've been on. But as you're sitting there just kind of meditating, you do lay your head back and you begin to sleep. As you do, you kind of
Wake up, snap up, and be like, it's not time yet. Do you want to dig through memories to see if you can find something else when you sleep, or do you want to go through the book? Sleep again. What's the rule? Give me history with advantage. History. That is a 23. As you lay your head back and you begin to sleep, the first thing that comes to you is the memory of being in a place similar to this one.
of the altars, of the chains, of the demons. It was a little different because they were draining the blood off. It was a strange cult. And they were consuming the blood. And of course that brought about the warping of their skin and the distortion of what they were and they became abominations as they entered the moor and opened the door to possession.
And as you are going through that memory, it feels like you can walk alongside yourself and look at things. Because everything, just because you didn't see it in the moment, you saw it. And you're able to just look at things that weren't, that were in the corner of your eye. And as you were walking along, alongside yourself in the memory.
You just stop. Something catches your eye that wasn't important in the past. And as you walk over to it, kneel down, trying to see it, it's hard because you didn't focus on it in your memory. Give me an inside joke. It's just too easy. Something about it strikes a note like you've seen it since you grew up.
There's a piece here. There is a piece here that you have completely missed. It's the key to... You get up and you begin to walk alongside yourself as you continue to move through the memory. Maybe you'll come back. As you do, you're looking. You're looking at the halls, the ritual designs, the cult. This was a cult of rumors. This was a cult.
that reached for powers beyond the thing. And as you walk, you find several firstborn of powerful families that are dead. You and yours. And you remember now, and as you continue on with memory, do you want to focus on the fallout or stay in this memory? Stay in the memory. So as you continue to move through this, as you're looking at them,
Something catches your eye again. You walk down and you lean and there's a dwarf lying down on the ground with the cloud, the thing, the hood mostly covering their face. It's hard to see. You didn't catch it this time. Try again. See if you can make out the different features. This is a different. This is a... This would give you again an insight into your dream. That's a lot better. That's a 17.
You didn't catch it the first time. You didn't catch it that time. It was a great song. With that, you stay in the memory. You follow that. You jump ahead to a meeting four months later. The head of your order has called you in. And they said, you're going to have to keep you guys out of line of sight for a while. A lot of beards got singed.
You did a good job, you did a good thing, but the Firstborns probably weren't acting without the blessings of the top of the family. They were playing with things they shouldn't, obviously. But there's a faction amongst us, it's a growing faction, that needs to be made sure it doesn't come to power, that believes that mixing of the demonic, refining it, is a path to power worth pursuing.
We have our eye on them, but for the time being, there's nothing we can prove that they were involved with. But it doesn't make sense that those children would have been there doing that ritual and that process without their blessing. They didn't have the resources. They didn't have the means. There's also a growing faction in the military that thinks that we should turn the enemy's weapons upon themselves if we could harness some of the factions of the...
undead and mix it with the demons they could have this super army that they could throw in and use against the undead hordes it's folly it's folly of course but it's a big it's a small faction in the military but they've been growing i've got some power to make things rough on us right now and something we have to keep an eye out for so
We're gonna take a little time off. I'm gonna have you guys go team up with a special branch to start working with some of the elves, some of the halflings, and some of the other races. Our enemies are not just internal. They have enemies and a dead demon is a dead demon. It doesn't matter where until the heat comes off. We'll be reassigning you to work with them. It's not fair. It's not right, but...
It's politics. Until we get some dirt on them, you can't kick the door in and kill them. So, you did a good job there. Thank you, sir. Sorry about your losses. Part of the job. Always is. That's why fools like them are the true enemies. With that, the train fades. Get a long rest. Um, when you awake, um, guys, with the completion of this portion, um...
You will be getting two levels. Two! Yay! Unfortunately, Josh, you have to take a level up. You were not able to complete the level. Unlimited credits, maybe. Unlimited credits. So, you get your little bump. Get your little bump. Level five, folks! And I can't wait to be level five in the next part, right? Yeah, yeah. Level five wizard. [Review note: two level gains are announced; the class required for Alistair is unclear in both recognition passes.]
Oh, that will be a big deal. That's actually a pretty big jump. Squishy to whatever fly is survivable. Okay, so the rest of you guys, as you move up with Rurik, up along through the woods in the dead forest, you decide that it's better to follow the cliff up along instead of trying to hit the old road and come back in. It's a straight line. So you guys begin to work your way up. And as you do,
There are spiders watching you, but none of them attack as you work your way back up. Was it just us and Rurik, or did some of the animals come? They stayed because you went to the temple. Yeah, we weren't going to bring any along going to the temple. So as you guys make your way up along the cliffside, moving your way up, you continue moving along and...
At one point, you guys, Alistair, your ears keep picking up something moving alongside you in the forest outside of line of sight. It is flanking you, but it's not coming into range. It's staying out. It's following you. Do you guys want to do anything different or just move along quickly and quietly? As quick and quiet as we can.
Just keep it keeping on. Are you wanting us to add those levels now or wait till the end of the session to do it? Um, why don't you, let's wait till we get this role play part done and then you guys have time. As you guys move up along, because you haven't long rested or anything. You haven't. So as you guys move up along the cliff side, there is, uh, like I said, there's something following you on one side. And then, uh, perception checks.
I was gonna say if someone's following us I'm keeping an eye on it but oh that's a big number that's a 23 well that's good because I got a 12. yeah so good because we don't have the minus three now right since we left that place uh you do not have that anymore you guys can remove the minuses um as you guys are moving along um with your high you had you had 23 which was highest right
24. Okay, so with a 23 and 24, you figure out after a little bit that it's the driver that was watching you earlier is flanking you out there. Okay. Walking along. But with a 24, there is a brief moment where you know as darkness shifts and walking amongst you non-aggressively is one of the drought.
She just steps through darkness to you and is walking alongside you. This is one of the workers at the brothel, shall we say. The casino. Did a good job back there, getting them to do that. Regrettable that one died, but the real question is, why are you heading up this way alone? Looks over at Rueck.
And why did your men leave the book? You answered as Rory. I'll say as for him, he's got his own reasons. For us, our old companion has something of ours we'd like to have. We don't reckon he'll be needing it, but he's decided to keep it. He can keep his share if he wants, but we would like ours. There's kind of a grin there, Jules. You did earn it fair and square from us. Ah, we did.
Will you be passing through the portal or heading back into the... She just kind of looks at Alistair for a second and goes, towards the water. Can I look towards Rurik? Again, I'm not going to answer for him. We're going back. I'm going through my bloody portal. That's kind of you. Do you intend to close it behind you? Do I have reason not to? Yes. Then I won't. Very well.
I do think he would want you to have your stuff. We'll see if he isn't a talking weirdo. He's been rather obsessed. You know how men get when they have an obsession. Especially him. I think he's a little past the average. You gonna press it or what? Oh, we're not too far out. We'll see if I can get it for you. So we'll be at the fort. I appreciate that. We'll get out of your hair real quick.
All have done us many services. I would ask you if you're doing one of them. Depends on the job. We're under contract right now, so I don't know how much I'd be willing to divert from. It's been obvious that you had no, have not talked to them about the temple. At least you haven't. Nope. I kind of smirk with that. I don't know exactly why.
That mean you told you about the Hadozee betrayal? It would not have included you. They were supposed to. And they would have followed through. That is regrettable. I did kind of. Well there's still plenty left. Yes, but they're not castles. Fair enough, I guess. I don't know if there were genetics and breeding. It's not probably any of yours. That's more your friend's department's fault.
You put back magic development in them for many a generation by eliminating all that had the gene to pass on. If they don't have any children, only their children may pass that gene on to others. These Hadozee are quite the fascinating, fascinating, fascinating. Perhaps you've never seen them. As they say, a caster of the Hadozee will be rarer than his teeth. And you have to find.
A cockatrice to give hands to you. Chuckles. If you are interested, we'll be in touch. She pulls a ring off her finger. He hands it to you. I'll gingerly take it. To contact you? To contact you. I kind of put it. Couch. We're pretty tired. I don't know how much more we're going to be doing out here. We've already done a lot for fucking every faction out here.
She's still walking alongside you guys. She's gonna glance down at you. I'm surprised you're leaving. Don't you have unfinished business? And he's walking along. Yeah, I have unfinished business. I have saved my entire race. That's fine, buddy. I've just done that. Don't expect to see you often at the passage, but the way is clear. And there'll be a thank you for you for leaving the department. She reaches out.
pat your head like she like she tried to do that a year ago and your ear you know does that little fear careful with my rabbit he says shoot i'll be sneezing for the next hour now look what you've done as a friend she laughs and from one step the other she steps through the darkness so as you guys follow the way up without disturbance you get there
go through the tunnel and his portal is sitting open on the ground there. Alongside with the portal are bags of the crystals set up around it that they have used to funnel the energy into it. And sitting next to that is the back of the portal. Well, all right. I'm gonna pick it up.
I'm gonna say either of you want to be the one to carry it. I'm already carrying the rest of our gear. Fucking alright. I just toss it in the party's one. Real quick. You can't put a bag of holy in a bag of holy.
He doesn't have a whole bag of holding. Oh. Then I would just probably take the... I'm fine with taking it. I could take it too. Anyway, while you have this discussion, we're just going to look at you. I was going to say, I'm going to take out a handful for my own pouch. I've got 250 out and about, but I'll probably pull until I have... I have five, so when you're like, the bank and the bag are inaccessible, I'm like...
So as you guys start to grab some of this money and stuff getting into the bag of goldie, do you get some out? Jose? Yes, Jose. Yeah, I would pull some out. Give me an inside check with advantage. All right. He's stolen. 17. The bag's changed somewhat. You don't know why. You don't know what tickles you about it, but there's something about this that's a little wrong, too. The bag?
Still a bag of holding, but it's a little different. Something about it tickles something that you've read in the past. But you still can reach in, get your stuff, no issues. Everything works fine. Might just be the fact that he had to sever the back of an art history that he created and usually may taste the magic, so he changed it or something. But as you're interacting, something about it just tickles something. Rurik looks at you all and goes, well...
This was definitely an interesting experience and even though it didn't play out the way I was hoping for it's sure gonna be beautiful to see the look on that smug bastards face when he helps them race hit all the crystals be sure to have enough in there to Defend yourselves if he gets violent looks and is anyway, I guess
You still owe me, but you don't owe me as much. He smiles at you. I still have the forgotten memories or whatever, the note of, you know, if he didn't make it through, right? Yeah. He's like, if you still want to help me save a species, another species from extinction and dying off, follow the breadcrumbs I left you.
It'll be one hell of a reward for you if you want to do it. But I'm not forcing you. Once we get out of this, we'll figure something out. Oh, that's interesting. Anyway, I would strongly suggest in making your way back to the rabbit folk if you can. They're going to be all spread out the way this is playing out. Things might get a little rough. But, then again, all things could go tits up in every one of the valley guys. And they might be the only ones who make it.
He salutes you and goes, all right, be safe. It was a pleasure doing business with you, and thanks for finding an old friend. I always pay my debts. That's too good. We do too. Sir, good luck to you. And to you and your kind. He goes, I'm going to add a second bag of holding and transfer the stuff from just standard party equipment to one that says, which one of you guys grab that other bag? I'll grab it.
So then I'll have a second bag of holding in the party inventory tab that says you're getting it. And with that, he passes through the portal, burns up the crystals that are available there. So the portal is still there, but it doesn't have enough to maintain, not to transport. You would have to gather crystals or have some kind of other power source.
So with that, you're now on the trail and you can make your way back to the river. Did Bevar take out his quarter? No. Okay. So I'm doing the math right now of how much we have. So if that's... Because he would have half of his original in a bank. Yeah. So we wouldn't have access to that, but we would have seven-eighths of the total amount. Yep.
With half of our amount being there and half being here so we have the number in the bag in the party inventory already So oh do you have that number already? Yeah, it's a inventory tab. Yeah Inventory page click on party inventory. Yeah, I forget that exists. Yeah, so and also I'm doing physical character sheet, so I'm really doing much Yeah It is so
As you guys head back, there is nothing to stop you as you make it and you are tired, very tired when you get out and you can go to the side and you can take a long rest by the river or you can keep pushing on and take a level of exhaustion to get back to the town a day ahead before the inquisition does and maybe 12 hours before the rest of the Humboldt folks catch up to you. Or you can rest and wait for them.
It's your call. But while you guys decide that, you awake from that night of sleep and that dream and that connection that you hadn't made before. You reach to see if the red is still there. How much blood number are you taking out? I have 10 already, so I'm going to take out 490. 490. I'm taking it out right now. I'll try to go back to sleep to see if I can remember. As the ritual...
It's the rabbit folk end up and all the animal folks they leave about me just for a long rest and get back the quantity and use your kind of pace your eyeshade just kind of remember things really can't sleep The book starts out
These are the tales of... and then it was a standard Thor Dorben name. No one, no family of known. He goes, these are my memories of the end of the world and the loss of all that matters.
And as you begin to go through, it is the tale of poor people in the Dwarven lands who got cut off from the rest of reality. Don't want to cross the threshold. In its own pocket realm. And there was simply not enough resources to go around. And how the rich, the powerful, the leading families, and the military using, and this is where the first time they refer to...
the Legion of the Dead, or the Damned as they're called. And as they go through the descriptions of this, you begin to realize that the faction that you put a stop to came to power from the Dwarven Empire in the 5th age. And the elite of the elite began tying themselves to demons and using
demonic powers to modify willing and unwilling people into a special army. This army, we'll say it's split up. Gathered up all the civilians that were not needed and barely kept them alive with just enough to stay alive. And then they would take
50,000 and they wouldn't come back. And they'd take 60,000 and they wouldn't come back. And they'd take 100,000 and they wouldn't come back. And then it was the day they took a 250,000 and she was in that group. And they led them into a large room and they imbued a $250,000, a 250,000 orphan.
mass sacrifice through ritual to generate enough power and for whatever reason her bloodline allowed her to pass through reality but not to one of the worlds they were targeting because she wasn't she ended up on another world and it's the tale of her understanding this other world and interacting and this book the um
And as you get to it, it goes up to a point and it stops because there is another piece of leather. Like she had sewed on to an existing leather book and she goes, this is what I had my hand on when everyone else died. Give me the history or insight check with that image. There's that. There's there.
16. Fix it a little bit better. Remember that thing you couldn't quite make out that you'd seen before? It's the book that had this sewn on top. You hold in your hand the original book that was used
in these demonic stuff that was on the floor discarded and overlooked somehow. And as you flip it open, you and me feel a presence push against your mind. Do you wish to engage in a mental conversation? Or should I say... Yeah. Yeah, you can say that. As it touches your mind, you feel that pressure come up against it. I wasn't born yesterday.
You close the book, and you look across where the Justicar is kneeling. And as he feels his eyes, he opens them and looks at you. He looks at the book as you told you it was Grim reading. Yeah. The, uh, rhymes aren't exactly what I was hoping for. At least I'm learning still. At least it was a short read. I'm sad it ended where it did. It would have been interesting to have known what that other world was like. Maybe how it ended back here.
He rises, stretches his back. I think it's time I start the ritual. I think enough time has passed. It'll take another four or five hours of cleansing. Another routine. If you would watch over the entrance. I'd always draw people. So, as you go to the entrance and you stand there alongside many of the others. Things... A very disturbing set of thoughts.
are beginning to run through your head. And certain core feelings that you couldn't point and figure out for your actions that you took are beginning to fall in line. You might make those choices. And with that, it is 15 till 8, or 15 till 10, and we'll sit and we go to 10. So we'll go ahead and wind down this session. We've taken a pause.
Are you going to wait, take a long rest by the water, gather some crystals and wait for the animal folks and then head into town 12 hours before the Inquisition? Or are you going to push on to the town and beat them by about 24? What were you guys thinking? Did you discuss it at all? If you push on through, you'll have a level of exhaustion, but you can always rest once you find out the situation. I feel like I would like to approach.
Well rested. I'm kind of in the same boat. I think we should be well rested. And have four hours to gather crystals. And then, yeah, a handful of hours to gather crystals and just absolutely load up our bags of holding as much as we can in that time. And then move on from there. Yeah. Okay. And with that, we will be ending session 12. I hope it was an interesting session. Oh, what you got?
I want to check. I hold it in the ring. Okay. Okay, yeah, I'll definitely give it over to you. Okay, let's do that first. I will mention, I don't know if I said I mentioned it earlier, but I will mention it probably on the walk back, if not earlier, that I think there was something different about it. Okay. So, that, as you get there and you do your thing.
So tell me exactly, you're going to do identify on the ring that is in, is it in the Discord? Or which ring? It's the one that Drow gave him. Yeah, the ring that I just got. Okay. The ring has a sending stone attached to it. It's built into it, it's a ring of sending. Yeah. It also periodically sends off a little...
message like a peen like here I am okay I need you to read me the specifics of identifying okay I almost have a hundred here debating which direction I go I can either get it's kind of annoying if you take ritual caster as a feat it doesn't put your spells on your spell list if I go monster hunter I get another five style
I can take a reaction to attack before someone else attacks. That thing's disgusting. And I can get my hunting yield, so my subclass. Or I go continue into fighter. I get my fighter subclass, a weapon mastery, and a ASI or a field. Okay, so your fighter subclass.
You touch an object, the rock is forced to cast you. Do you know what spell class you're doing with your monster hunter? No. To be entirely honest, I would definitely say taking that second monster monster hunter. You can have another or any ongoing spell that could affect the item. The item is breathing by its value and that's the ASI. I'm not taking an ASI this time. I'm taking a level more cast rate. I'm taking the second level of fighter. And oddly enough...
identify does not work for a medicine class. Okay. I express that to the folks. I guess I should read the last line just in case. If you instead touch a creature throughout the casting, you learn which ongoing spells may be affecting it. That line is a fact. The bag has a... It does have... The creature has the appearance of a bag.
and has a dimensional storage space with it. The whole bag of holding? It's a fucking mimic of holding. It is the bag man. There's a bag man in our bag? Or is the bag itself the bag man? The bag itself is. Which is why it triggered for you. As soon as you go, oh, it's alive! That's when it'll click for you. God damn it. Just feed it. And it won't come.
Or fucking pull everything out and get a different bag of holding when we can. Good thing, but it doesn't take up an attunement slot. I mean, bags of holdings don't. They don't. They're doing half the time on my games that turn on you like you can't... It's an attunable item. No, it's not. Alright, I always thought it was attunable. That's why you never take one. Yeah, no, they're not an attunement item. They just sit on your head. Yeah. Okay.
If you're an artificer, it takes one of your slots. That's probably what you think. My ring of holding was an attunement slot. That's right. Because it had half the space, but it could keep food preserved. It was a stasis one, not a... Alright, so you have a dirty little monster with you. The Bag of Devour technically is what you have. How much do I know about that?
As a monster hunter. You've heard of them. You have to research these. Okay. With that, we will be bringing this session to a close. Hell yeah. So, um, hope it was interesting and fun. Oh yeah. Uh, you guys did more damage on that than I was expecting. I honestly was expecting people to die.